three two hello hello it is Friday June
9th and it's all happening today
actually
we are uh sitting amongst the council
again because even though I tested
negative this morning
technically I'm not in the clear until
Sunday
so I have two more days of nail biting
covid excitement
but you know what I'm I'm excited
because today yeah I don't know if
you've been watching but
um this is our this will be our third
show of the week yeah the other two were
quite bad oh yeah
I might have to disagree but okay
they were they were quite they were not
well received this one this is the one
I'm confident is gonna be fantastic so
I'm glad that you guys are all here we
have a great show for a change thank you
you always save the best for me always
always
and uh we're joined of course by the
beautiful lovely Hill doggo
um we're joined by the council you got I
don't know if you can see them all there
yep yep it's just one shot right damn
it's just one shot you only get one shot
that's awesome I missed the council so
if this was
the Last Supper then
is Sam Jesus or Ian Jesus
um if memory serves me I think it would
be Ian and then if Ian's Jesus then
Olivia would be Judas right I think
that's right I think that's right I'm
Ryan
you're wrong at the Last Supper there is
today there is now
Ryan everybody hated that Apostle Ryan
that guy was the worst man with a name
like Ryan
uh we are of course uh
uh here we have a great show let's take
a look oh yeah Trump got indicted and
for the second time and because we
didn't do leftovers I mean I gotta talk
about it's like the biggest news in the
world right now explain it to me
excuse me he wanted to vape and I've
been avoiding news very peacefully well
we have a whole write-up about it but
essentially it's regarding the
classified documents yeah I thought
already though
you got raided for it yeah a couple
months ago now the charge now it's the
official charge and it's quite bad
there's like seven counts and then this
morning two of his attorneys resigned
did they yeah
[Music]
and the crazy part is bring my boy the
worst the worst one that I've been
hearing from uh political analysts for
him is the one that's he hasn't been
charged with yet coming out of Georgia
about the phone call where he was like
we just need to find seven thousand yes
please no no no that one apparently is
the most dangerous for him this man is
just racking up the indictments dude
he's about to get a uh
he's about to win tic-tac-toe on the
indictment board
yeah all right well that's exciting
let's see and then there's some actually
really interesting new
alien footage a lot of people uh a lot
of Believers out there
so we're gonna watch that
you know I'm a hater me too but I'm here
with the open heart and open mind I'm
waiting
all I ask for is one HD photo
that's all I want I feel like Trump
could be an alien
HD photo ever used the photo of trump
if anyone could pass as an alien I feel
like Trump could interesting been
replaced
he's been replaced three times already
oh yeah Kanye did too he's in the third
iteration
Kanye has been replaced I didn't know
that's a theory that does make sense
though he has been acting different
uh what else we got uh oh Pat Robertson
died which is fantastic
this is a huge ripogo moment although to
be real
did live to 93 so like he he kind of got
the dub on us yeah the worst balls
always do this is one of the it's a OG
uh psychotic
Evangelical evangela W Angela kiss he's
just a total [__] demon if there's
hell he's definitely going straight
there okay yeah so we made like a
montage of him
we got all kinds of stuff but first
let's talk about Marvel collection that
just came out yesterday
congratulations
you're wearing a special outfit yes you
want to show it off yes you want to try
the catwalk just okay let's try it yeah
but I don't have them prepared for it
you just push the button I mean I have
the camera are the camera's ready yeah
yeah okay so you need to you need a
remote right to turn it on no
um here I can run over there and turn it
on real quick here you showed Teddy
fresh I'll get it set up so we brought
up it on there
is so we brought out I have this
standing treadmill that I just don't use
anymore
used it like three times
and um
ela's gonna use it as a catwalk for you
guys pretty exciting
there's no railing and it's quite small
too all right so here is Ela
and the acid acid wash denim uh jacket
okay now let's get now give us a walk
yeah there it is dude give me the
what's that little music video did you
care
okay she's in the the acid wash denim
jacket
repurposed denim pants into a skirt
and uh repurposed
waistband into a top
hey
we're having it
[Applause]
can you walk backwards no I don't want
you to die
[Music]
there you go I guess that was somewhat
of a
didn't
[Music]
yeah but here check it out we didn't
talk about it on the show yet but very
excited about this collaboration
we've got all kinds the Spider-Man
stuff's been doing really well I guess
that's not a surprise and the Marvel
Universe oh man this is my one of my
favorites today I'm wearing my uh
Doctor Strange OG Doctor Strange yep
we also have the um
the same thing with Venom I really like
yeah they came out like really yeah I
love my happy happy yeah and then uh we
got Bantam we got
Wolverine up in this
we got the Thanos shirt I love this one
too yeah I was gonna wear that one but
I didn't the button up uh I don't know
if you showed that Oxford this one yeah
Oxford button up for if you're going to
work work okay interesting work
statement why not wedding I don't know
long sleeve Doctor Strange shirt this
one slaps pretty hard
um and one of my favorite ones this one
is sick by the way though
I'm Ghost Rider there's three like this
with these really intricate embroideries
and it looks so sick
um it's hard to tell but this is a whole
embroidered plate
the holocorn is so cool that one's uh
Loki which one love the hall corn the
purple Hulk one oh the She-Hulk biker
top yeah oh yeah no no the hoodie on the
right there oh this this oh the whole
one yeah this one is insane bro yeah did
we put one aside for you
you can't tell because it looks so good
but this is a super intricate embroidery
So Dope very cool yeah
and then
there was this one which is uh
this is Thor on the rainbow uh the
Rainbow Bridge the Rainbow Bridge oh the
bifrost
that's right Dan
so there it is check it out see if
there's something you like there and
thank you guys so much
Maybe
Marvel
it was really fun to take all of our
favorite graphics
Ethan and I oh my God through Labor they
have like so many options and each
category it's like a different era you
need to pick an error and like stick to
it and we were the most inspired by like
this old like comic book look yeah and I
mean the artworks are awesome the
artwork there's a lot of amazing stuff
but there was like thou literally
thousands of [__] we had to sit for
forever but yeah that's a better better
than not having enough assets which
happens sometimes you'd be surprised
when you collab with the IP they're like
here's three images yeah what the [__]
uh speaking of uh collaborating uh Gabe
is here
hello Gabe
of the white claw variety where are we
today just out there
I'm out there
they're there you're out there right
[Music]
I just gotta share something that I hate
I oh I hate okay what
I hate pickles pickles are not do
are you gonna eat one right now
no I'm just gonna throw it out
why do you have to take a break I
cleaned that [__] [__] so you bought a
pickle just to throw it out I mean what
are you doing
I'm throwing it out
why'd you buy it what kind of people are
we talking about pickles I think that's
not a good pickle hey hold on hold on
Gabe don't do it
no way oh my god dude okay we're pouring
pickles on the sidewalk this is
basically Zach taking a [__] on
someone's grass that's not a pickle to
represent all pickles that's not the one
something I hate those look like sweet
pickles yeah not the butter not good no
[__] okay Gabe is that so you we just
have a whole bunch of pickles there okay
yep
I hate let it out of my mind and I feel
better [__] okay the pickles have been
uh I feel better for him can we insta
card to get a good pickle and see what
he thinks later in the show Gabe are you
up for that
yeah I heard yeah
throw that [__] out oh another [__] wait
there's another can
there are orphans that would be eating
those sandwiches I don't even like
pickles I eat them I'm kind of with them
orphans love pickles pickles you said
they're okay I don't what I'm not like
I'm not like Gabe okay
well some pickles are great most pickles
are sometimes a pickle can can hit for
me but I'm not the biggest stomping on
the pickles is he okay
what did pickles no no he's not
are you okay buddy
the pickles hurt you it's nasty yeah
it's nasty it's just nasty I don't I
don't agree with it in my mouth [__] I
tried pickles before I I try to like
them on a burger it doesn't agree with
me okay I just say let it out Gabe Ela
had an idea yeah if we instacart you our
favorite pickle which is the Bubby sour
and Dill Pickles best pickle by far if
we instacart that to you will you call
back and try it for us
no oh man what that's just nope
so narrow-minded today Gabe what's going
on today I'll try again try it [__] it
try it he doesn't want to try if I don't
like it I'll spit it out yeah you can
spit it out if they don't like it out
Theodore always said that you know when
we're trying to get him to try something
new because if I don't like it can I
spit it out or like yeah you can get off
Dave Phillips useful
so you're down to I mean I don't want to
force you it seems like you have a real
issue with Pickles yeah right the only
issues The Taste that's true right
that's the whole thing yeah that's a big
I guess the only other thing is right
yeah okay I'll try it
damn he's pissed sorry dude
all right so Sam you have instacart on
your phone
I'm I'm already on it so get the but the
Bubbies Dills
[Music]
I think let me fact check that Bobby
like like Grandma yeah yeah exactly yeah
b-u-b-b-i-e-s kosher dill pickles I kind
of want to get one delivered here too
yeah because Dan has been slandering too
here I'll try it I I oh have you not had
Bubbies I don't know I may have changing
bro I may have but life-changing here
I'll try it I'm not I'm not gonna be a
baby like Gabe he said he'd try it
you guys there too yes send us I want a
jar of the kosher dill I'm gonna eat
these you know it's just it's just
Bubby's whole kosher dill pickles right
here that even looks like my bubby on
there dude this lady knows what the [__]
she's doing I'm telling you there's all
kinds of morons pickling [__] and just
you know they throw up some vinegar in
there some dill whatever they think they
know what they're doing no Bobby's been
doing this for centuries wow
best pickles in America it says right
here
they're super expensive too by the way
it's like 12 bucks for one [__] one
last thing that's what you pay for
Quality 10 9.99 the ones I'm looking at
are 9.99
Price is Right Champion right there I'm
open to high quality pickles to see what
it tastes like dude it's so good I'm
telling you
um okay
you know what's cool about pickles zero
calories it's like eating yeah
I didn't even get that how does
something have zero calories except for
like Diet Coke but that's just like a
chemical this is like a cucumber
I'm eating it yeah I feel it it's got
weight zero it doesn't exist I think
yeah cucumber is just 99 water water
well cucumbers have calories not a lot
wait how could the Cucumber have calorie
and then it doesn't when it's pickled
that's what I'm telling you dude it's in
a it's a pear it's a pickle Paradox [__]
look a cucumber according to this chart
a third of a medium cucumber has 10
calories so you're talking about if
you're talking about eating a whole ass
cucumber that's 30 calories
a medium cucumber no they do that
that's what I don't understand you
cannot all the pickles have zero
calories they go into your stomach and
then evaporate
no I'm telling you uh on look on the
info it says zero [__] calories here
yeah it does I remember that Bobby
pickles um
nutritional that's my wrong
nutritional uh chart there's a bunch of
people in the chat saying they are uh
grillo's gang look at those games zero
calories
how I think it's like that sugar thing
we talked about last week it doesn't
matter metabolize I'm reading I think
the body yeah look at that sodium though
I am boy yeah
salty treat but you know it's funny too
they go serving size half a pickle it's
like really ain't nobody eating half a
pickle they're not even that big they're
kind of big
I guess it depends on the luck
I've seen bigger
all right so Gabe are you picking up the
pickles now Gabe what you what's going
on back on Gabe a pimple watch
we're gonna throw it away You're gonna
pick it up throw it away responsible
King you're good you're just kicking it
into the street that's not throwing it
away
it's not throwing away at all I don't
even think Wildlife can eat that no it
might be poisonous to Wildlife oh Gabe
pick that up like birds aren't gonna eat
that [__] coyotes pickles I think so I
don't think it's a problem okay can dogs
eat well it has a bunch of salt so
they're not supposed to have a problem
okay pickles are not toxic to dogs pick
up those pickles
why is everybody saying gorilla's gang
what is gorillas Sam get those girls
those are the vehicles bomb ass or brand
wait oh yeah okay let's get that too oh
did you order already got Sam is like
I'm working on your order right now okay
so get me the everything we've ever had
it you know what I think I've tried it
it's not as good as Bubbies but we'll
get to the bottom of it I love the
package though so cute really good get
me the the like yeah the classic Dill
hot I like the hot ones he's chilling on
the chase Lounge but these are a little
bit spicy which is which I love I mean I
think on packaging wise Bobby's still
wins because it's so classic like you
can't beat it but this is a good second
so cute wait what the [__] is this 85
how big is this goddamn container
all right Gabe thanks man we're gonna
get you some pickles so Nick Nick you
guys will call back when you guys get
the pickles
yes okay thank you all right we'll talk
to you soon okay buddy
all right thanks for taking that Leap of
Faith with us to try the pickles I
appreciate that all right he's not happy
about it
oh
he's back back
I just start to think like he's the king
then we're doing a podcast yes
it's me all right okay we'll talk to you
soon okay
all right
yeah all right love you yeah
go Yankees
Yankees baby go Yankees
oh
so oh speaking of White Cloud Gabe he
actually put out a new Banger Cameo that
I want to show you guys yeah you dude
this man he knows how to give
condolences that's the one
something about uh
let's take a look
oh
there's no audio Dan
oh audio audio audio audio audio
dragon
yeah I'm sorry you got this owned by
your by your mom [__]
for being a queer oh my God
if that pissing my ass
thank you
for being a queer but
everybody's the same Ray cause you're
the best
[__] yeah don't let anybody tell
that you're different cause everybody's
the same we're all different right we're
all different but we're all the same
that's true who gives a [__]
everybody's different right they're the
best thing
that's that's a banger it's so beautiful
dude and that was a powerful Pride
minute 53 seconds absolutely so
whatever they paid for this it was
actually Priceless yeah no they got
their money's worth 100 percent
uh top comment we can always count on
Gabe to be on the right side of History
absolutely absolutely always
unproblematic King uh Eli you had a
banger IG post I wanted to show this
thank you
so this shoot was so cool that you guys
did actually yeah that was your idea by
the way yeah so we were all like okay
Marvel is coming up what are we gonna do
for the photo shoot we want it to be
like so badass and we just finished
shooting our Godzilla where we did the
set then we're like What do we do next
because we don't want to do another set
and um Ethan was like you guys should do
real pyrotechnics because it sounds like
an idea that's like how do you even do
that yeah and that we were all like uh
how
we found a pyro Technic yeah and uh he
showed up with like a truck of a whole
bunch of flammable [__] yep Sam can
chime in too on this year of working
with this guy oh yeah yeah he was great
he was he was so awesome for this he was
perfect
he's like a Hollywood guy right yeah he
doesn't oh yeah yeah I mean he's worked
on a lot of really really big projects
like a lot of Marvel stuff actually so I
mean you could tell he knows what he's
doing he's badass it was super cool so
there it is so congratulations everybody
on uh Marvel thank you oh and one other
um
what someone on the subreddit was
excited about the Marvel collab and they
made um
this fan edit check it out this is the
first time for me in the Marvel Universe
oh wow that's so good wait one more time
I missed the very beginning of it this
is the first time for me in the Marvel
Universe was that even was that me or um
Owens whatever his [__] name is
the first time for me in the Marvel
Universe you can't beat that first one
man and you can't beat it I like the
Aquafina one a lot too hey my name is
[Music]
really good
IES Pinocchio
um so how's everybody doing out on the
council anybody have anything
interesting to report on this beautiful
Friday
I just want to say I love our audience I
just I just appreciate them and I love
them happy Friday everyone
AV was catching all right
that was a nice positive thing to say I
love the yeah I love the positivity but
Abe was catching Strays I guess after
the
after the office
um presentation but i i j so there was
two posts I they were in Jess they're
joking I thought the posts were fine but
I guess when you go to the comments ab
and you start going down too [__] far
big mistake you can't do that dude big
mistake I have no I have no idea what
you guys are talking about it was all
love
it's all love it was all love I love the
presentation I thought it was fantastic
oh thank you I mean it floated the whole
show for Christ's sake I haven't watched
it yet I have to admit I'll give you
I'll give you a summary it was a full
presentation yeah about how I'm Dwight
and then somehow everyone came to the
conclusion that I'm trying to say I'm
Jim that's that's pretty much it that's
all you need to know
well it wasn't that obvious that you
were trying to say you were Dwight
I guess not you're right
but the thing is you are you are not
accepting the Ryan everybody says Amy's
Ryan he was pushing against that well it
was because I was making a presentation
about how I'm Dwight I'm making a
presence you said you're a half Dwight
half gym right
yeah yeah but then but then like my
reason my reason for being Jim is
because I look at the camera which is I
thought clearly obviously I am half Jim
I can't say that but like the reasons
why like like Dan and Ian were Jim were
so clear but me I was like oh I look at
the camera
he thought it was self-evident that
him trying to be Jim makes him Dwight
when really that made him oh you went
super deep It's So Meta yes I guess so
it's just too advanced dude very
Advanced sophisticated
it was just annoying because I I was
making a presentation about how I'm the
most hated guy in the office to white
and they won't even give me that you
can't have that you're not Dwight you're
Ryan man are you guys now I'm right are
you as Dwight yeah
but I haven't watched so I need to watch
the presentation
[Music]
yeah
so anyway but he did great and we love a
b right guys thank you thank you we all
love a b don't don't be so hard on
yourself don't read those comments man
no I was proud of it I thought it was
fun Lena really liked Jay you guys did
you like that that was fun that's all
that but I just I just found it funny
where did you start reading it in the
Reddit pup comments
uh it's everywhere that's the thing like
people think I'm looking for this stuff
like it's my job to go on Reddit I had
you know I mean like that's where I find
that's true I mean well okay but let's
say if there's a post about you huh
you don't have to go super deep on that
one
well I know but I I you know I put a lot
of times I I am curious about feedback
you know that's fair I write the show
part of it and I uh
yeah that's fair but I like went into it
like smiling like oh
can't wait to see all the gods
it wasn't really fun though to be like
going down memory lane and seeing all
those clips
I can't wait to watch it that's what I
thought too it's just like a great look
back and I mean a b had my ass nailed on
Michael Scott as much as I wanted to
push back on that it was if you wanted
to push back on that yeah no I thought I
was like you know the upper management
you know
Michael's boss or Idris Elba oh my God
yeah yeah I think I'm an Idris Elba
personally just really cool hot in
control right that's how I see myself
effect on women
right wait wait
who would love me what I'm wondering I
had problems with love and with you
someone on Reddit said Robert California
for love and I thought that was such a
good idea wait who's Robert California I
feel like when Love's love is in office
It's Gonna Change
a lot for sure oh this guy
I like it that's kind of funny kind of
funny I don't remember what what his
he's kind of characteristics
dude he was a psycho yeah that was like
your friend right that would do bad
stuff no he was their manager for a
minute oh that's the minute yeah
it's awesome
God's friend okay Todd Packer yeah
that's Jimmy Lee yeah
that's perfect but you see Amy the the
conversations continue and we all love a
b we honor a b well thank you appreciate
it he's he is the best there is a post
however on the subreddit
love is obviously Ryan okay but I
wouldn't say that's obvious he is the
one Michael considers to be hip and with
it
that's a good point I mean okay
I guess love is hit I mean yeah love is
kind of like the
When Love laughs everybody knows it was
actually funny
well he knows all about twitch and all
this like new age uh Media stuff right I
would be the guy that was really into
crypto too which is kind of love so
that's right well people are saying Ryan
made a website that as well Ryan
oh you know what yeah I'm I'm buying
this yeah it said they continue love
would be the first one to make business
schemes like Russia right especially if
you were there in person he's the hugely
online one that's the hyper trans TC
yeah yeah you know what fair enough
strong argument there yeah Ethan is
always looking for validation in the
form of him chuckling yeah
you got me that was pretty funny all
right fair enough okay that leaves
so uh you might not have to worry about
it yeah right I don't but you're not
like you're not Dwight enough do I it's
like I know I'm just trying to I'm like
that's what made me because I like I'm
playing the character that the that the
audience has assigned me since I've
started working there and it's like nope
you're not even this you're not even the
simp I'm not even the Sip no more like
what's going on it's different it's a
different kind of simping I don't know
how to describe it yeah
I am a simp
yeah I mean in a sense though Dwight is
super resourceful super hard working so
and like in the sense you are both those
things
right you know and then just like you're
just a little more hip I feel like or
whatever the word is to to like
to be like yes it's Dwight yeah but
that's why I mix everyone like that's
why I was Dwight and Jim
all right let's move on thank you baby
we love you
complicated conversation yeah so we got
a whole bunch of good stuff including oh
you know what would be good for a title
Dan's new chair everybody's waiting uh
the bathroom well first of all you just
spoiled everything by presenting it that
way so okay sorry but second of all the
uh the episode that we actually do it is
gonna be in a couple weeks that's the
one that we should call that right
that's true so guys as everybody knows
Dana has been suffering in the Scorpion
chair it's a monkey paw wish that
essentially has gone wrong he wanted the
Scorpion chair he got it he got it I got
it careful what you wish absolutely
terrible here but listen getting Dan a
new chair is not something that we can
just do Willy Nelly I did not just going
to Ikea and buy a chair my what we need
to do people want the bachelor but we
can I'm not I'm not down with the
bachelor anymore because I
we know why it's too much there's too
much uh land mines
too much Tony 23 you know what I mean
so what we're doing is combining our
favorite H3 reality show The Bachelor
with Dan's wanting a chair The Bachelor
how does it work make submissions on the
subreddit using the bachelor Flair back
Chiller do we have the flare set all
right uh hopefully I'm making it right
now as we speak there you go it'll be up
in a second by the time most people are
watching this episode it will be there
uh it can be a it can just be photos
photoshops and a text submission it can
be anything you want but essentially
back if it's pre-made or if you've
dreamed something up we want to do the
best
the best effort we can to make this
winning chair real for Dan I love it
similar to uh the bathroom proposals
although that was that so it can be even
like a custom that we will need to build
absolutely it doesn't have to be an
existing product it does not necessarily
have to be an existing product nobody
chair or in my dreams or your nightlife
because the question is do you get a say
in this or is it fully up to the fans to
vote well that's not how the bachelor so
all right I choose right yeah so then
too okay so you're gonna choose your
favorite one yeah I think that shouldn't
discourage people from coming up with
funny horrifically torturous ones we'll
include those they'll be discussed you
know what I mean I probably won't pick
yours but I feel like there should be
two brackets like fan bracket okay Dan
bracket audience favorite
coin yeah
do you want the um
cheeses
the flare is up the Flare's up
yeah so the winner by
and we'll be doing this segment in two
weeks the Wednesday before the live show
so get those submissions in it is the
bachelor
yes
he is the bachelor
beautiful soft butt to sit on back
yes
all right so we have big Nick you kind
of love big Nick
he's so awesome what a big Nick is
and his most entertaining uh he's a
Content game yeah he's hitting hard
actually you know what's actually crazy
in Christian Tick Tock he is quite
successful sensation I mean this video
that we're gonna watch is utterly
it's just so dumb and weird
and yet it has 25 000 likes wow so let's
take a look at big Nick who's been
hanging around with the murder porn guy
I don't know
yeah so he collab with murder porn guy
and now he's coming out saying he was
gonna kill people ended not only in my
life but other people's lives as well
long ago growing wait hold on let me see
why yeah big Nick is saying he was
homicidal I would have ended not only in
my life but other people's lives as well
long ago growing up I always dealt with
extreme he just goes on but Jesus do we
want murder porn guy and big Nick who
both are having a recital idea why are
we admitting all of a sudden that we're
murderous
let's keep that on the DL please well
you pause this video maybe he has a good
reason
condition which caused me to have short
stature I experienced so much pain and
rejection due to this and I would even
cry as a child because I felt like I was
a mistake as I got older I constantly
was made fun of my people for something
that I could not control it was so
painful it is they didn't use this as a
way to create bitterness and rage deep
within my soul it is sad and I we all of
our hearts go out to him but then he
loses me when he's like yeah trans
people are demons and and uh gay people
should burn in hell forever it's like
what
they were born like that too dude that's
what you gotta understand man right you
can't be like
yeah you can't be asking for sympathy
and then other people who are born with
and the way they are and you're like
you're going to hell I mean [__] you
dude that's why I call him a little
Goblin
or troll sorry goblins are small right
in general and I mean in the Azeroth
fantasy setting of uh World of Warcraft
goblins are in fact small but in what
about Tolkien is Goblin's Tolkien
goblins is sort of synonymous for orc
and Tolkien uh legendarium actually so
it's it's ambiguous at times so goblins
are smart so I don't want to use goblins
because I'm not trying to comment on a
stature generally they're small yes so I
like to call them a little troll because
trolls are actually quite large and that
way I'm not making fun of his stature at
all right more just his inner probably
your fruits his inner being
so let's not call him a goblin okay
my whole
life I felt like all anyone ever saw me
as was a person who didn't deserve any
respect yeah he just keeps going that's
crazy but yeah he said he wants to he
wanted to kill people but I would have
ended not only in my life but other
people's lives as well long ago what
so I'm scared I never wanted to kill
somebody yeah it's kind of I guess like
out of context I could see a bean
ugly you're disgusting I'm gonna kill
you
so we can expect good things from those
two guys together that kind of scares me
that now we're seeing two people saying
that that's it that's like the Bible is
like you know how Trump made it like
people are not afraid anymore to be
ignorant and you kind of made it cool to
be stupid right
I'm afraid that there's something
happening here there is all of a sudden
it's like in scaring me because I think
it's like they want to prove no I was
the most [__] up person until I found
Jesus look how much I overcame through
the power of Jesus and murder of porn
guy he's like he's like the Babe Ruth of
of newborn uh newborns he's like I used
to fantasize about killing my wife when
I had sex with her and everyone's like
whoa Jesus saved him so big Nick has to
step it up it's like an arms race he's
like yeah I wanted to kill people too
it's like whoa
he's like yeah I used to I used to
yeah I used to for I can't even say it
but I'm watching it I'm interested
sorry what hey what say what say what
women are not supposed to be speaking in
churches and women are not supposed to
be taking Authority roles I had sex with
this guy in a Walmart parking lot
let me tell you something he was not the
one taking the authority roll
first of all I love this I 100 believe
him I mean he admitted himself he was a
having sex with you if it's real or not
it's so funny I believe it's real I
believe it's real I choose to believe it
yeah
so there it is I love it bro if I see
big Nick and murder porn guy cruise up
on me I'm scared yeah nobody's scaring
me like those two guys right now
yeah big Nick if you want to call in I'm
still waiting
all right
uh no waiting yeah real quick can I hit
that are you done with that someone
someone
doesn't have their Discord muted on the
council
it is not me and I just double checked
Selena and she's good it's beeping every
time a message is sent so
done it best shop
my days are behind me of I'm playing
audio send a message then
oh oh
uh
who did it keep going I'm muted
okay
so some but wait if you're muted does it
matter
you know you know if you're muted it
doesn't matter you have to mute your
notifications separately yeah yeah no
don't you
I think so there's something that we'll
go through
no not a zoom I'm talking about
um yeah
well Sam is not here is it Sam
isn't Zach the only one sharing computer
sound oh that's a good point I just got
a good point I just checked all my all
my things are turned off all my
notifications oh here I can do that too
if I send a message yeah if you just
send anything in the chat Ian are you at
Sam's computer
[Music]
I'm pretty sure that only Zach has audio
from his computer right but it might be
an open mic but all my notifications are
muted there shouldn't be anything going
I hear it I hear it when he all's got
notifications
I'm just spamming
I'm just spamming messages in our
discard I got headphones in so he
wouldn't be here for me anyway so could
it be my computer somehow
no no
now I mean I I see it coming in on the
sound board through the zoom feed so
it's audio from Zoom one way or another
okay okay y'all need to Yo somebody's
[__] up over there how do we how do
we do this Dan is there a way they can
mute I don't have a way
oh yeah can you mute on your end I do
one at a time Dan interesting well I
mean it's probably some right who's
everything hold on hold on guys keep
doing it keep doing it okay okay mute
Zach first
okay
it's Sam
wait how did you know
I I now that I'm looking at the uh I can
see that her mic is activating every
time it happens it's Sam where is Sam
here let me go one sec let me go find
her who is the man the one person who's
not here
um
also just real quick I just
there were people telling me that I was
wrong about goblins and Orcs being the
same in The Lord of the Rings oh no
I'm sorry you are wrong is
is Tolkien himself wrong is that what
we're saying let me read poking himself
wrong yeah the term Goblin Dan couldn't
be wrong you guys are stupid
primarily in The Hobbit but also Lord of
the Rings where it used it's
synonymously with orc I said they're
basically the same I didn't say orc I
said troll
no I said when I was explaining Goblin I
said they're basically the same as Orcs
yeah and Orcs can be larger because we
were talking about the size come on
that's why the World of Warcraft
universe is better that's yeah it's way
way better than more realistic but
aren't the urukai different Orcs too
yeah the urokai are uh half breeds uh
they have a lot of human no elfs right
and what's the what's the Orcs are
actually uh elves they're they are
corrupted elves that's where Orcs came
from and then urukai are crossbreeds we
can we can wrap this up okay I see that
makes it a lot of sense Samantha is back
we can move on
thank you you're muted now
I was needed wait okay no I'm not
I'm Gonna Keep
oh you can still hear it it's back
[Laughter]
Ian you wanna
you you interested in helping her at all
yeah hold on all right Sam are you not
meeting muting your can you are you not
muted I'm muted right now you're not
muted yeah you're muting Discord you're
muting yourself on Discord it's what am
I doing wrong yeah
Zoom your Zoom needs to be muted no go
into Discord and turn off the
notifications
no no no I I see well she was muting
this card wait can you I can't hear it
anymore oh
did you fix it Sam was she just herself
that we can't hear you Ian's gonna fix
it so uh moving on we talked about FaZe
Rain who went uh against
the again thanks girl yes against women
against all women his war against all
women and I think he I think he's lost
it oh no
he's getting a lot of [__]
and so here's his response I say find
God in the end I don't know how to
describe this I don't like saying this
but I don't even know how to describe it
other than schizo posting
well it starts out normal I guess so he
goes imagine you say two plus two is
four
but 10 people let's say they have blue
hair Ethan Klein
he said I have blue hair I'm still
scrappling with that come along and tell
you two plus two is in fact five
am I going to believe them because
there's 10 of them and only one of me
[__] no
two plus two is four Now find God here's
the thing about so far so good the math
checks out
yeah but you being like women be lying
or whatever that's not math that's like
right that's like a subjective opinion
for sure but at least like I'm just
saying on the mathematical level I'm
following so far okay so you guys
following so he keeps going but yeah I
understand what he's trying to say right
pair so then he goes BHM what is that
to be honest I don't know
BHM has infiltrated this poor person's
minute taking two blue hair mindset oh
blue hair mindset
bro you gotta move on on the blue hair
thing I mean that's that's so like I
don't know 2015 like triggered yes
culture it's like sjw yeah
I mean we've we've moved like a few good
years
of cultural
variations and conversations about stuff
like that it's definitely I don't see
anyone with blue hair
okay so he this person said you're a
good guy bro well get educated before
you spread this BS and he goes is two
plus two not four Checkmate got him
though did get him face up
but some people think very black and
white even though 75 percent of my
thought process includes cold hard facts
awesome 25 of it acknowledges the human
emotion and factors and how someone
might feel
two plus two is four but oh my God one
plus point five plus point five plus two
also equals four
this man I'm full phased up right now I
mean man spitting you must account for
more possible variables in a life
equation you mean like uh
a woman doing something that you like
men only
you must account for more variables in
life man only
oh he sent me a DM I don't think we ever
showed that
I don't know if I was even aware of that
yeah after the podcast we did
[Music]
explain I'll read it did you explain how
much two plus two is the distance
before he found like this really deep
before he found God yeah before he did
DMT or something
he said bro what is this podcast decided
to watch the new one because of a tweet
and you're so passively trolling I don't
know how to take this passively trolling
I mean I was yeah I wouldn't have been
passive at all
like there's no way you guys are
analyzing my hairline what the [__]
okay yeah
I mean History podcast
yeah he says just watch the video I
posted today the reason I was acting the
way I was because I thought we already
squashed it y'all just be riding [__]
crazy
oh yeah that's what stood out to me I've
never heard that in my life
[Laughter]
y'all just be riding [__] crazy it's
just people like visual like I get
exactly what you mean I guess
the way dudes need say like hop off my
dick girls should start saying hop off
like hop out my clip [__]
I might yeah I might adopt that he
continued everything is understandable
for her and anytime it's me you choose
to portray me negatively you're
absolutely unbelievably biased any
illogical it's crazy laugh my [__]
ass off no I'm not laughing it sounds
like you crying and then he says also
we want the stock to go down you [__]
okay
just tell me you messed up you were
talking about the other phase Reign
which I just found out was a thing today
there's two phase Reigns what there's
two-faced rains you can face
stop what you can't have two phase Rings
wait are we talking about the same
person
also did he he's this is the two plus
two one the same guy as the last week
yeah it's the same guy yeah okay oh my
God and then he then I responded I said
what's the hunter phase right like
I don't know he's probably catching some
Strays after this he's a great guy he
does charity work he works in the soup
kitchen he's beloved
he has blue hair actually
I'm kidding I don't know okay so I
responded I said ah I said no what we
said what she said about your drug
problem was Mega [__] up we said that
but on the whole I think you started it
and we're a way bigger dick and then I
said what's a [__] Rider
[Applause]
um wow if you were a part owner of a
company and you own a bunch of stock in
it are you allowed to
just publicly state that I'm trying to
tank the stock of the company
I mean it wasn't public but
unsolicited message I guess sort of
public I didn't ask I don't know enough
about SEC laws but that seems weird to
me
I don't know nothing about nobody in the
audience then
so um
let's see here
oh yeah let's keep on with the math
so okay now this is where the math angle
this is where he starts to lose people I
think while I'm mathing if you multiply
11 by two numbers
that have added together don't equal 10
or more you can cheat the answer
11 times 27 is 297.
because 2 plus 7 equals nine
and you just stuff the nine in the
middle laugh my [__] ass off
11 times 34 is 374.
but if you do
11 times 38 it would be 4 18. the
strategy doesn't work there so
unfortunately you need a brain or a
calculator works too so then if the rule
doesn't work
then it's not a rule I just look stupid
man I think I just found a different
strategy for numbers above 10. let me
look into it yeah this is concerning
there's more isn't there yeah go to the
second tweet in this thread
there you go okay
this is like he's drawing this on the
wall with his own feces or some [__]
if I win his own business because he's
like in a pre he's like in a an insane
asylum just painting with his own [__]
about numerics and stuff
so if the sum equals 10 11 times 55 is
605. take the right number push it to
the third digit add one to the left
number and add zero in the middle digit
if sum equals 11
hello
does he know what sum means
yeah I think he does I think it means
like the two numbers
like if it's 38 then three plus eight
what yeah but some is when you like he's
multiplying here some is that's what I'm
some is when you add them but you're
saying he's adding the five five yes
so he says take the right number and
push it to this is like Facebook magic
kind of math you know yo join my new
Ultimate phase class on how to math like
yeah like a phase up
to uh multiply so if it's a sum equals
11 so that yeah you're right that'd be
three plus eight yeah 38 that's odd dude
above the ply also I'm pretty sure this
is this is like a known I don't think he
discovered this is what I'm trying to
say
yeah I'm literally there's probably a
video about Facebook
[Music]
if there's some known mathematical
pattern somebody discovered this like
200 years ago
but he says if you follow the pattern up
based on the sum the pattern still works
I love how consistent math is two plus
two is four brother I mean me too
this is such a mad place all right
okay so what you do for this new pattern
is you break it down like this 11 times
38 push the second number to the Right
add one to the number to the left and
one in the middle
right this is just about multiplying 11s
crazy because I actually just figured
out this method while explaining the
under 10 method laugh my [__] ass off
bad bro you follow me he's smart
if sums equal 12
11 times 66.
equals 362. push second number over a
digit and add it like this one two six
under six what does the under one mean
was he doing Sudoku yeah
anyway he's just demonstrating yeah yeah
I think this is
your brain on face which is awesome you
know the era where we used to burn the
witch I remember really stop
the type of witch was burning changed
right
well said
and the short circuit is so funny yeah
this burrito's good you don't want
anymore
I I ate a good amount I just it's still
messy for me to eat during the show so I
sacrificed for the show
you know what I mean you follow me
Queen [__] thank you
dude
we haven't talked about Aiden Ross in a
minute
but this is the greatest Aiden lost Ross
clip Aiden lost clip I've seen in a
while W so his he's talking to his
manager I'm not fully over a face Reign
but we can move on I mean what do you do
I'm still enjoying it it was that was
lovely
maybe I guess there's not much to say
we have another award for his well-being
but
it was very entertaining before we play
this can we just preface it by reminding
everyone how he was talking so much [__]
about us and about love and he's like
yeah and [__] you guys I'm Gonna Keep
[__] grinding I'm gonna keep making
all this money
yeah yeah wait you talk [__] about love
there was an episode he was reacting to
and like he's like what are you even
talking bro what the [__] where are you
at what do you say about you love make
funny keep [__] gambling [__] yeah
get homework get off my Cliff bro
[Laughter]
anyway he's talking to his manager
and also apparently the dude he's on the
phone with
is also a manager of other big people
like Travis Scott okay and Aiden Ross he
used to get a bunch of huge names on his
stream yeah and that's what helped him
grow to these Great Heights of
popularity
so he's asking his manager
yo why am I not getting these
celebrities on my show and his man is
starting murakami there in the back just
on the floor
it's
it's that hard to tell w
I it's hard to tell yeah so um his
manager who's obviously over his [__]
gives him a very blunt on his live and
it's fantastic guests bro like where's
Drake streaming where's future stream
where's boozy stream where's Travis
stream get me some people on my stream
bro
yeah I would be getting it
and you get your reputation is just so
toxic like no one wants to be anywhere
near you like Drake is literally
streaming with like a guy on here who
averages like 4 000 [__] viewers
rather than getting on your [__] it's
like really sad
wait so it's because I'm a brand risk
uh duh why do they care
yeah they don't want to be associated
with a guy that's saying like [__]
having like Nazis on his stream I
stopped having not he's I stopped doing
all right but you still were doing it
dude and you were [__] I mean you're
very closely affiliated with Andrew Kate
so a lot of people are afraid of that
just in general like you know it's these
guys are afraid of their reputations
they don't want to be seen with like a
guy who's like dude and all the gay [__]
too like there was people that were
trying to be on your stream that were
like uh is this guy gonna ask me weird
[__] like they're afraid of like you
know they don't wanna that was one
person and can I say who it was
who
you know who it is the fat guy
isn't that fantastic he he's really
ruined his own his whole career in this
effort to like be yeah
to be like Andrew Tate's little uh
Gaston henchman what's the name of it
yes we always forget what yeah
he's he's going to Romania
to visit Tate and house arrest good
maybe this can have a conjugal visit
there
[Music]
I I think it's quite sad I mean you've
basically thrown away your whole [__]
career
and service so fast of Andrew Tate this
is him I don't know if you remember
this he Gaston oh little [__] boy it's
so perfect so perfect oh Gaston
the Beautiful the ever rapey Gaston
Jesus yes the man is a rapist
there's no there's no two ways about it
that's true really yeah oh yeah
the amount of times Bell says not
interested
right okay fair he's definitely a sex
criminal
Aiden hasn't been the same since he
stared deep into his sister's [__] on
stream that changed him do you think
that was the yeah Joker moment but I
just find that so so fantastic so uh
[__] uh Aiden Ross and um
enjoy uh get your career is destroyed
for basically no reason
[Applause]
[Music]
like what did he gain from doing all
this dumb [__] got it being like
homophobic transphobic like he said
having Nazis on yeah he gained 19.
literally like bigging up Andrew Tate to
the highest possible levels sniffing
Andrew dates
chair right right just humiliating
yourself for views absolutely remember
that of course who confused to be such a
good little Jewish boy with the punim I
don't know what happened I shouldn't put
him huh I don't know what happened I was
Bar Mitzvah all that [__] it went
downhill yeah Aiden Ross on his all this
is well known to be his alt this is not
a debate yeah he's been tweeting at
Hassan Hassan please kill yourself I'll
do anything please what yep
was like dude
bad tweet Nico
oh man
that's rough
sneako's making him look crazy
um
there it is
you know there it is lovely I love
catching up on all those uh poses it's a
nice one too just subtle
oh there it is uh so we did this all
right so let's I guess let's talk about
the main story here uh oh you know
before that let's talk about Pat Uh Pat
Robertson because we prepared something
special for him
he's one of my favorite uh demons along
with um
what's that one guy's face with the
devil eyes
oh um Kenneth Copeland yeah Kenneth
Kenneth but who is this guy because I
don't recognize him well we have a
compilation of those Great Moments amen
but he he's he died at 93. yeah so he
kind of got the dub in that sense appear
too long man well
eternity in hell should be
right that'll make up for it what's his
net worth he probably was super rich
dude
how tall is he good question Dan let's
find out
I got scared when I first I just saw
that what when I first saw the headline
I'm sorry go ahead the zoom is [__]
me up because it's delayed he's five
eight Dan
yeah he's on the shorter side
he is he's on the shorter side
doesn't sound that short it's not it's
just Ethan always ask her I didn't make
fun of their height Dan you said what's
his height I said okay
the only thing worse than going to hell
is being [__] five eight in hell
that's right that's right I didn't say
that brother dude
yeah anyway
it
I support short Kings I Tower over
everybody with these shoes now yeah are
those like lifts what's going on no dude
it's like a normal it has a normal heel
because I always wear like zero
I choose and now guess what everybody
gets experience right
right
your new sandals they have like a little
like platform type Stitch right that's
right off to the side Ethan so we can
see how thick they are I mean damn look
at that
for for sandals they give you a little
bit but I'd say compared to tennis shoes
they're still smaller so
we have a much smaller good point maybe
I'm actually even taller yes so I
thought you sleep seemed a little more
imposing and Powerful when you came back
yeah you're right I do
you weren't you didn't uh hallucinate
that
so yeah this guy made a hundred million
dollars just basically
scamming his audience was he I think he
was even selling like fake covid cures
like no no underwater no you are
confusing him Baker Jim Baker's another
one yeah well anyway this guy is
genuinely significantly worse than Jim
Baker or Copeland or any of them really
really he's had no plan far more of a
tangible impact on life in the United
States than any of those guys this is
the guy that essentially started the
hardcore Christian right in this country
like he is responsible for getting
evangelicals as a block to start heavily
voting Republican well it's prior to the
uh late 70s and 80s that that wasn't
like an existing Coalition like
evangelicals voted Democrats sometimes
here's the deal if there was a God he
would have killed him long ago
I'm telling you but here it is uh our
tribute to Pat Robertson
[Applause]
it doesn't matter what custom you've got
it doesn't matter what holy thing that
you worship on the door the gays are
going to get it they're going to make
you conform to them you're going to say
you liked anal sex you like oral sex you
like bestiality you like anything you
can think of the tools whatever it is it
won't stop at homosexuality my wife has
become a real problem she has no respect
for me as the head of the house please
tell me what I can do well you could
become a Muslim then you could beat her
and this man's got to stand up to her
and he can't let her get away with us
what was that he said you could become a
Muslim and beat her but then he goes why
but also Muslim I don't know because
Christians beat their wives I think
that's even like that's part of the vibe
of it
I don't think we condone my feeding
these days but something's got to be
done to make her she does not understand
Authority when she was growing up nobody
made her behave she is acting like a
child now what do you do with that yeah
you can't divorce her the most racist
[__] you know they're racist
when they go who they say they're what
like what do we do what do we do about
all these my minorities
so he's actually saying
the Muslims have it right because they
can still beat their wives so he's like
I think that's his point right it's
because he goes on to say wife beating
is not acceptable anymore but we got to
do something about this lady right yeah
no I think you're you were correct I
don't know but I'm Muslim when I saw the
pope earlier this week I said please
remove some evil from this world and he
followed through so
oh you think he granted your wish this
is I wasn't specific but I don't know
yeah you got three wishes from the PO
then he shrinks and goes back into his
uh
his Jesus way for a cup I think it's
just God's Gift the pride month this
year ah
that's a good point this man should have
died decades ago there's no dub in this
93 come on all the worst ones always
dude you see uh Henry Kissinger had his
100th birthday
Henry and he's not even healthy like
he's always been like nasty looking
overweight
there wasn't a time when he wasn't
incredibly old like in my entire life
like I'm 35 years old and when I was a
little kid Henry Kissinger was decrepit
and he's still around Henry Kissinger is
like a psychotic war criminal freakazoid
uh and he's still alive so kicking oh
here yeah that that's there you go Jesus
Christ the dark side is the pathway to
many abilities it was very rude to uh me
and my dad I went to a wedding when I
was like five years old and we were in
an elevator with him and he's like he's
like can you move out of the way please
douche [__] you that's probably the
worst thing he ever did [__]
it's a total [__] dude how are you
I always have these stories Zach like
yeah when I was a kid I ran into Henry
kissing during this one time yes so um
he's still alive yeah I I don't know
they we talk about the baby blood
drinking and stuff but why are these
people living so long they clearly
something's going on here right yeah
yeah so back to him you might get AIDS
in Kenya the people have Aids you got to
be careful I mean the towels can have
AIDS the the left is having a dilemma of
major proportions and uh I think for
those of us who you know disagree with
some of their policies the best thing to
do is to sit us on the sidelines and let
them kill themselves but I want to say
it again and again and again Islam is
not a religion it is a political system
meant on bent on world domination not a
religion we have we have killed over 40
million pigs he did I'm telling you he's
been at this for a long time oh my God
this is uh in the wake of Hurricane
Katrina it's like one of the worst
national uh natural natural disasters
unborn babies in America what God has to
say uh in the Old Testament about those
who shed innocent blood and he used the
term that those who do this the land
will vomit you out that you you look at
your book you look at the Book of
Leviticus and see what it says there
found that we are unable somehow to
defend ourselves against some of the
attacks that are coming against us
either by terrorists or Now by natural
disaster could they be connected in some
way when we like things on Facebook if
it's something that goes against what is
written in the Bible such as pictures of
same-sex couples is that considered
condoning the behavior and you've got a
couple of same-sex guys kissing you like
that well that makes me want to throw up
but if you think of you punch to me I
would punch vomit and I'd like
can we get a vomit button on Facebook
all right
slam that vomit button I love just so
tolerant
I've been begging the Zuck for a vomit
button for when I see a minority
they're both sitting in this setting
like so proper and everything and then
they say the most nasty [__] yeah it
looks like they're on The View yeah yeah
well if they were in like a cave or like
a damp cave where they belonged then it
wouldn't it wouldn't hit the same but
that this is what I was talking about
this is why he was so influential he he
is the OG like televangelist there's
this thing the 700 Club and I think at
some point maybe it still is uh was like
a 24-hour it was just like a channel on
your TV that was basically just
[__] main lining like just far right
Christian intolerance essentially crazy
on TV
and it's delicious as cam just said yeah
so there's the Christian Broadcasting
Network CBN gotcha welcome this is where
my jokes come from when I go uh I'll
tell you what man there was a storm in
Alabama because two gay boys yeah
[Music]
that's right well he was saying because
of uh abortion right is why Katrina
happen he was saying abortion is why
Katrina or every baby aborted that's one
more
cumulus cloud
created by God
up in the stratosphere
and as them cumulus clouds come join
together and holy matrimony those
humorous clouds they do and they doing
God's marriage
amen they come together
like an orgy of same-sex goodness
that cloud get bigger bigger
till it turns hurricane
of gay dudes kissing and dead babies
oh God
sometimes I like to look out the window
when I see them storms coming and I
touch myself
I touch myself because I I want to
praise God
all his power all his mind
he's always with me he's always in me it
ain't gay if I [__] God
because God is everybody
and so as I see Katrina come rolling up
[__] on my window glass
I got a nice beachfront property Florida
came on my window glass there
one of the first time either
my window on my window they keep saying
the phrase window glass you know what
that means
the window pane
[Music]
no the glass right but it's called a
pain
okay whatever bro the pain putting
you're giving me pain right now
[Music]
come on the glass there
was the first time neither sometime it
dripped down make a pile of [__]
still love
and I just leave it there a testament to
God kind of like a shrine
sometimes I come out in the morning and
I notice the ants is getting in there
[Music]
shout out it's rumored that 20 people
died in uh Nigeria
did you see the picture Ebola from this
kiss do you see the pictures in New York
with all the smoke yes right here right
here
how did you forget
sorry about that
sometimes I get a pile of it
kind of like freeze-dried semen right
stop
and the Jesus and the Ants sometimes I
wake up there I'll leave it out like a
shrine but the ants they coming they
think it's food
and They carried it off I tell you man
my pile be a lot bigger if them dang
ants coming in and they put some semen
on top man sometimes I like to put a
little uh pesticide
um
one time had a friend over he asked for
sugar in his tea I would run out of
sugar so you know what I did I took his
blown Spoonful that freeze-dried semen
Jesus it's a little sweet a little
softer I tell you I hate this to tell
you what brother you ain't never had a
better cup of tea
semen tastes good
um
semen tastes good all right whatever
they don't give you that option Lego why
do you say Lego Lego is watching a Lego
Corporation they're watching this is why
we got rejected oh why they hate us well
they already rejected us what could be
worse I guess so [__] you Lego maybe
they can make a Lego Hell
Fire set Lego hell yeah oh my God it's
got like the Pope the last Pope hey B
that's such a good idea it's got like
Nixon
George Bush buy that for like a thousand
oh yeah let me see like a super special
that's actually a good idea for like an
artist to create yeah like Lego hell
with all the little pieces yeah fire
Saddam Hussein
that's awesome we got a guy maybe he can
make it for us all right Facebook but
anyhow you can donate yes you can donate
it something happened a long time ago in
Haiti
pickle update pickle update
oh the purples are here
this is huge the pickles are almost here
people let me even finish this video
Alfredo and the people might not want to
talk about it they were under the heel
of the French and they got together and
swore back to the devil they said we
will serve you if you'll get us free
from the French true story The Devil
said okay
and they kicked the French out you know
the Haitians revolted and got themselves
free but ever since they have been
cursed by by one thing after the other
desperately poor they need to have a
great turning to God but what is this
what the f how does he know all that he
goes I tell you what man there was a
pack with the devil I seen it
I've seen the photos and the videos and
everything wait so he's saying
all of Haiti's Misfortune is because
they rebelled and what they had a slave
Uprising no they made a deal with the
devil to kick the French to be able to
get the French and so
and this was also for context right
after this Christ this was right after
the 2010 earthquake that killed I put
200 000 yeah 200 000 people so you're
saying the devil my dad is yeah that one
is like yeah oh no even the other [__]
that was in there that's [__] nuts
yeah how is it like seriously how are
things like that even okay on TV well
this was probably I don't know 20 years
ago maybe
I feel like I wasn't even able to
capture like his worst of the worst
moments too a lot of this lost media
because I went on this Wikipedia page
and I couldn't find
the worst of the controversies on video
but these are some bad ones mac and
cheese is that a black thing it is a
black thing Pat but this is only
oh my goodness this was two days after 9
11. we played again it's the beginning
of the black the mac and cheese one
mac and cheese is that a black thing it
is a black thing Pat but this is also
that's funny but two days afternoon okay
the beginning it was sayings the bin
ladens the what we saw on Tuesday as
terrible as it is if in fact God
continues to lift the curtain and allow
the enemies of America to give us
probably what we deserve well Jerry
that's my feeling I really believe
[Laughter]
okay that's that's that's interesting
nice pickup on that parallel Kim totally
alive that's awesome I feel like I
really believe that the pagans and the
abortionists and the feminists of the
gays and the lesbians their reasoning is
slightly different the reasoning is a
little different yeah we're actively
trying to make that an alternative
lifestyle the ACLU people for the
American way all of them who tried to
secularize America I want the thing in
their face and say you helped this
happen you did this y'all all you
seculars and gays you did this all right
it's 9 11. he's like uh well that was
that's foulwell saying all that right
he's like a commercial version of um
Alex Jones like a digestible version
yeah I feel like digestibles I guess
question I'm not sure
I totally concur because he's like on
all these shows enjoy your time in hell
yeah
there it is
rip Bozo and
um all right so let's go up and see
what's going on with our boy wait the
pickles where are the pickles Sam said
well they're here
um I can run down and check real quick
I'll just leave it I'm just gonna leave
the camera on you guys yeah go ahead
what did you mean Sam you said gabes
were delivered but Nick oh cause Gabe
can't do it himself
Gabe can just prop the phone up can he
Gabe
yeah because Gabe's supposed to call in
and do the pickles with those yeah I'm
not sure if Nick needs to be there
um I'm waiting for Nick to respond to me
right now but my app says that they were
delivered so I'm just waiting to make
sure they received them
I'm actually super excited about these
pickles but I'll tell you what man I'm
gonna I'm gonna text Gabe yeah by the
way I started playing Diablo for
how's that been yeah it's good it's fun
it's fun yeah I gotta say I'm impressed
my expectations were low but I think
it's
seems like a really good game those are
here God that's like a whole what in
God's way God damn
wait what the [__] how many pickles do
you buy Sam
Christ dude there's an order minimum on
instacart okay okay wait this one is
Orange what's orange is it spicy spicy
coaster dough I know I've never tried
that one yeah and then here we've got
the uh the other one Sam we just got
three jars
they should be there now they were
coming from different stores but getting
there at the same time because no store
had both of them
all right so let me show you what this
is all about
we're splurging on these picnics let's
start with the with the originals so
you're supposed to shake it you see how
cloudy it is I don't know if you guys
can see that yeah somebody was asking
why is it cloudy because it's good
because it's chock full of good flavors
all different flavors so if you guys
there's a good chance you can find these
at your grocery store not everyone has
them
but uh there's probably one around you
yeah come get one of these but it's
usually not where all the other pickles
are it's like in the fridge because it's
like a
yeah the other pickles don't need to be
refrigerated wait Sam you're saying that
this isn't everything
no though we don't have the other pickle
no the other ones are arriving right now
oh my God it's not very sorry I don't
like the big one it's all good uh
they're like out front yeah yeah he's up
right oh yeah
let me ask uh Jeremiah if he can he's
Jeremiah's not there did you want to try
one okay I do but let me go grab the
other ones so we can compare so the one
you're eating now is the one that you
guys already know and love this is the
bubby
the bubbies
on Monday I'll try one if if there if
there are any leftover that would be
insane if there wasn't I have three
masses I mean who knows maybe you'll
you'll throw them all out just like yay
so now can we have some particular ASMR
let's see here it's a big thing on
YouTube
[Music]
what love
pickle ASMR it's pretty much YouTube yes
yeah the crunch just pickles
yeah it makes a good sound it does this
one has a good crunch
[Music]
side note when I found out that Pat
Robertson died I misread it and I
thought I said Robert Patterson died
yeah I freaked out
[Music]
all right so now we got the grillos
we got we got two grillers no here
that one's mine
let me give him one
of these yeah I'm gonna get one of the
little ones which one do better yeah
that's perfect
all right I want to see Dan's reaction
is Bobby
this is Bobby so good
boobies
all right
slightly out of breath because I just
ran up up and down the stairs twice
go ahead Dan
good to me
a Bubby my first bubby
for my bubby to the Bubby cheers girl
rest in peace
[Music]
take your time with that blur the
flavors
oh yeah it's crunchy the crunch tastes
like beef jerk that's good right yeah
that's good thank you that's real good
cosine these are the best can I say that
again
not a big pickle pan but this is good
good
for that now I'll tell you what
I can tell looking at these
brillos that I'm not gonna like it as
much and I'll tell you why I know
the skin
doesn't it's not going to snap like
those those Bubbies the skin on that is
perfect crunchy gives out these are
going to be chewy skins and that's not
what it's all about this way maybe it'll
be I'm gonna try it you know what I mean
try it
who's a big gorilla's Advocate is it you
Sam Olivia
well the chat was saying right yeah
they're bomb they're really good okay
again grab one of these
I don't want to cause a rift
I don't say it
I don't wanna
oh divide the community it's like
the Buddies yeah just on no level it's
pretty good it is pretty crunchy but
this one is like the sweet flavor
it's a little sweet but here's the spicy
one you want to try okay
also this is a problem this one has five
calories then Bobbies are not sweet and
I like that there's no sugar in it no
oh that's why these have five calories
huh a little sneak a little sugar in
there eh
I like the gorillas I think this one's
good too
which one's better
[Music]
I can't I wouldn't like Snap the
gorillas I think the Bubbies is a little
better they're Bobby but I would say up
close I think they're both real good
you see what I'm saying about the
texture of the Bubbies jerky definitely
yeah I'm excited for you guys to try it
man
yeah I love pickles I feel like I'm
getting kind of pickle cut right now if
I'm being honest but yeah hell yeah oh
yeah you are brother
oh
there's just two spicy ones the Bobby
spicy and the gorilla spicy but I can't
do that
I'm like pickled out should I did I miss
is is are we getting Gabe trying this
[Music]
um he's gonna join any uh any minute now
oh okay
so did we also send Gabe like 20 jars of
pickles Sam
dude
who just dumped pillows on the
dumped pickles on the street in protests
just got two massive jars I've never
tried this one though yeah
curious
all right why should we wait for Gabe
new boba tea meta
that's gross
eating just slamming pictures all
slamming pickles all the people do that
people do drink pickle juice no I've
seen recipes that call for pickle juice
I know somebody who does that it's not
about it yeah for vinegar and flavors
the person who does that is here right
now
oh you do no not me
anyone want to speak up you mean not in
physically no not physical gear but
present
why do I think it's them
it's got to be Sam I know I have
good
idea
she's lying it's Sam it's definitely me
um
I grew up on pickle juice popsicles
what the [__] dude that's why the Civil
War happened Sam I'm sick of this [__]
that's why we heard Atlanta
[__] the South
they're so good I'll make some I'll
bring them in on Monday what please
don't you should have to I it's so good
and there's like a little they would put
like one pickle chip in there and you
would like eat it I'd like to try it I'd
be so down to try that so good
dude
pick less popsicle what is wrong with
y'all
last weekend I tried pickled cotton
candy and surprisingly it wasn't bad
okay hold on what hold on hold on hold
on when you put cotton candy in liquid
it dissolves right
no no it was I mean it wasn't actually
pickle but pickle flavor sorry oh okay
yeah
that's odd too not sure I like that
either yeah I wasn't sure how I like it
but it's pretty good I'm gonna try the
spicy Bubby now
my pickle uh
my pickle stroke is passed
sometimes it just gets a little too sour
you know what I mean your pickle stroke
is off
it's wet
that's why I can't open it
turned off right now
ever let your see your girl yeah she
will lose all interest in you ladies are
you getting the ick right now
I once failed to open a pickle jar my
girlfriend of five years left me on the
spot
all right I gotta dry this because it's
all wet you know what I'm saying [__]
that [__]
all right this one goes out to Myron
Alpha oh no no coconut
oh [__] that's a man right there that's
a real man are they spicy
how is it
different not as good it's different
ladies but it doesn't sound like
they're all different flavors
it's not bad though I do like the spicy
Eve angle let me try it I just
yo you gotta get a small one that's a
huge one somebody in the chat asked if
anybody on the cruise gone to Mort's
Deli yes I've been there before who's
Delhi Morts I'm a series regular though
you're regular
oh yeah he's like oh yeah
under new ownership
Mark's gone what happened to Morton he
died and then they bought it and then a
restaurant group that owns a bunch in
the city bought it oh boy
rest in peace more rest in peace more
you change the matzo ball soup too which
I'm pissed about but you know whatever I
was always more of a Brent's guy
their soup is kind of mid guys let's
change the subject
okay
does anyone else have a favorite La
based Deli you don't talk about local
restaurants
Deli I live in L.A I have no idea what
you guys are talking about those are
validity yes but you should go I've
never had a little anti-semitic review
it's kind of similar too it's pretty
anti-semitic actually they didn't let me
in so answer me
what did you say love
I've never had a pickle bro stop never
had a pickle at all what I've had got a
pickle on a burger and I spit it out
every time and I've never ate take taken
a bite of a pickle like actually
or pickled things not like a thing
they would be yeah well what about that
[__] disgusting fish I mean that's
picked that's kind of pickled I haven't
I didn't never ate that before the show
either so you try to pickle once
I've only gotten pickles on burger
taking a bite and realized and spit it
out that's the only interaction with
pickle how do you know you don't like
pickles I've
since I was a kid I just don't really
like the vibe okay so you're gonna try a
Bubby when you get here yeah Bruce
already likes pickles
you know it's like zero calories
yeah
I'm like I probably don't like that so
don't try it you know there's a lot of
things I like
so I eat that I can't wait to subject
you to all these yeah horrible things
you don't want to do when you get here
and you can't say no too because um
right that is good
I've tried for the show hell yeah
all right let's talk about Trump people
as we wait for Gabe trumpy
suddenly what the [__] love that is not
true it's not true
I'm sending that to the uh consulate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right so Trump got hit with seven
different charges
well seven different ones 37 total
charges yeah what the [__] he's [__]
37 so here's a breakdown of what uh
Trump's being tried for
uh 31 counts of will for retention of
National Defense information
being charged by the Espionage Act
one count
false statements in representation
what does nauta so nowda I think is his
name it was uh like an age of his that
helped him in all of this and so some of
the charges are just Trump some are them
jointly and then that guy is also being
charged with some of his own
so what you know what's going to happen
he's going to go to jail and then Trump
will be like I I don't know I didn't
even know him well I think that
I think that I was hearing that that guy
may have flipped on him which is why
they have some of this info but I'm not
entirely well yeah they have I don't
know how they they have a recording of
trump saying literally and the Press has
heard it now they're reporting on it
he goes I have these documents that are
uh classified I could class declassify
him but I'm not president anymore I'm
not even supposed to have these
um like there's a transcript of that
Exchange in the dock if you want to open
and see exactly what he said because
it's pretty
[Music]
foreign
hold on we're having a technical
oh my God that was quick oh whatever
I'm not even yeah whatever yeah I don't
even I guess it's fine it wasn't that
bad people
nope it never is that's what that's okay
so funny isn't that bad no but that's
always been the case so far
[Applause]
we're on the safe side yeah better safe
than sorry yeah
okay so where were we uh so um one count
of conspiracy to a drug obstruct Justice
one count with holding a document or
record one count corruptly concealing a
document a record one count concealing a
document and a federal investigation one
count of scheme to conceal ooh scheming
oh and then not nowadays got one special
one one count false statement and
representation so shout out nauta nada
wow yeah so there what you guys are
going to hear is the entire conservative
apparatus
saying that Joe Biden had classified
documents right and he was never even
investigated and here's Trump being
arrested on seven different charges so
obviously the difference is is just so
you know because you're going to be
hearing about this so much that the
National Archive asked Trump politely
for him to return the documents if he
returned the documents when they asked
this there would be no problem no that's
what happened so then they asked him
again sternly and he again ignores them
then they get a subpoena a court order
and he ignores The subpoena then the FBI
gets a warrant and and raise his house
that is crazy he had three opportunities
including a subpoena
returned the documents I think one
correction to the timeline of that there
was a point where he turned some stuff
over during all of that but it wasn't
all of it right and that that after that
is when he got raided because they were
like return all this [__] and he was
like here you go and they were like dude
there's like half of the things we asked
for aren't here and wow then it got more
serious yes so um so when they say Biden
had uh classified documents that's true
but he immediately gave it back to them
when they requested and by the way it's
not that uncommon it turns out
that presidents accidentally take uh or
or maybe they take on purpose and they
don't understand I don't know they
taking these classified documents it
happens the National Archive says hey
we're missing this and then they return
it it happens right there's a huge
difference Trump took
[__] cases of this [__]
you'll see a picture the FBI took a
picture of it uh let me see here
here's where here's here was where he
was storing them by the way this is how
much [__] he took those photo rules just
in this
opulent in the [__] bathroom in the
bathroom this is really chandelier
bathroom by the way some of these
documents are so sensitive why isn't
there a chandelier in the bathroom
because he's Donald Trump baby Donald
Trump only the best
huh
so this is yeah that's a lot of yeah I
took this photo during the raid these
documents are so sensitive the one he
was caught talking about which is the
only reason we know what that one is was
like the U.S war plans to invade Iran
wow like crazy [__] yeah it's pretty
like high level stuff and he's like I
want this why did he want it like
because he wants leverage he wants black
he wants he it's valuable he's gonna put
it up I mean we don't know for sure but
you know
well why uh why not I mean what other
reason would there be for Donald Trump
and so you see the amount of [__]
and the refusal to return it after three
requests including a subpoena this is
not what I imagined in my head it was
like a few papers in a safe you know no
no no no like lots they were far safe
like on all levels it's so far from what
I thought it would be and then this is
so [__] up because this is at
Mar-A-Lago which is a resort that has
tons of people coming and going Trump
has this is his office bathroom I think
which is like how are you working like
that dude oh my gosh like do they
actually use this bathroom I think so
yeah I mean you could see like their
house here there could be some like
urinal specs guaranteed there are on
those documents
all over the people in and out of his
office he was having huge huge Banquets
like 10 feet away from these so not only
did he steal these extremely classified
documents they were supremely unsecured
yeah extremely actually by the way uh
here let me send you this is like not
only on secure
it's like like if you had your own time
if you had your own personal documents
then when you wouldn't be this Cavalier
with it yeah
check out what I just said oh no no
um
where did you send it in Discord
I don't see it oh it's not in the wrong
Channel
okay here we go here's more pictures of
the
storing of classes yeah so that wasn't
all of it
yeah wait what that would take like a
truck to move all this yeah no so when
he was moving out he told an aide to go
grab all this [__] that's the guy that's
nice oh that's the guy oh he got his Aid
and [__] yeah his Aid is all wrapped up
in it he's getting charged too that's
what I'm saying his a would definitely
uh flip on him hell no not taking heat
for your dumb ass well I mean he is
taking heat so maybe he didn't flip yo
there's more what
I mean these are all from the indictment
like these are because it got unsealed
this morning and so like there's just a
flood of like details about all this
coming out right now this is absolutely
insane
such a king and again these are my boy
he did nothing wrong these are highly
classified
this is crazy yeah
so remember that when they try to do
like oh yeah the
Biden did that [__]
so moving on
um
they have an audio recording which I'm
going to read now
and again Trump's defense for this up
until now yeah was I'm the president I
can declassify documents whenever I want
right he's like I Declassified it he
didn't there's an official process to
doing that there's one more photo
actually okay that
I don't recall being Ethan I don't
recall that phone explaining
the Bobby Lee one that's the photo of my
fat ass yep
I don't like the gorillas I'm sorry you
guys oh
canceled
I'm just not into sweet pickles it's
sweet you know that's the problem huh
man we sent Gabe like a thousand dollars
of the pickles and try it
I don't know what the [__] going on
with him he doesn't want to try the
pickles yeah he bounced Nick put him up
to it and then he bailed stick the
pickles and ran
yeah so Trump was like I Declassified
him so here they got a recording
of this conversation
which I will read to you Trump I was
just thinking because we were talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack country a and what I'm
assuming that's Iran right yeah
sever said you did Trump this was done
by the military and given to me uh I
think we could probably right staffer I
don't know we'll we'll have to see yeah
we'll have to try to trump declassify it
figure out a yeah Trump see as a
president I could have Declassified it
yeah staffer left Trump now I can't you
know but this is still a secret I mean
yeah Stafford laughs now we have a
problem Trump isn't that interesting
no
he's also saying that he wants to share
this document with somebody right yeah
yeah and which that's that's why the
Espionage Act and stuff is coming into
play with all this
uh uh because
I don't know if it's just like I mean
Trump seems like the kind of guy that
would just like want to show people that
because it's really cool like like
there's like some people that think that
he's like trying to sell the secrets to
the Saudis or some other opponent of
Iran or whatever and yeah maybe but also
he just seems like he would be like he's
so egotistical it's just like
yeah you know he just has like a
document collection you know like they
love card collections right
yeah that's possible
um it's bad and illegal either way but
so Hillary Clinton of course
who Trump ran his whole campaign about
lock her up
because of her uh mishandling of
documents
I was chilling in Cedar Rapids but
Hillary's actually coming out of the
woodwork to take a w here although I
have to say this is kind of embarrassing
it's so embarrassing he's always so
cringy with the timing of like she like
she had this is her moment
and she really is bringing out this [__]
check this out bringing this back in
light of recent news she's selling [__]
get a limited edition but her email hat
and support
you want to buy a shirt with this on it
guys or is it a hat it's a hat that's
bro I don't sell me that nobody's buying
that [__] nobody
it's some something that maybe somebody
else would do you know and it would be
sort of a meme but like you can't do it
as Hillary Clinton that's so
embarrassing
I mean
he did run a campaign against like she's
embarrassing he did run a campaign
literally on putting her in jail yeah
for mishandling documents and now he's
probably going to jail for mishandling
documents I mean I couldn't
I can appreciate the irony I get it but
there's but yeah this was the worst he
should have just come on Twitter and be
like so any news today I don't know
there's a million yeah sure right
thank you so somebody said she's such a
tryhard I think that's a good way to put
it yeah it's like it's ugh she just
never does it right she just never goes
right I'm just chilling here Cedar
Rapids
we were aligned on that one so let's see
Donald Trump has been indicted by a
Federal grand jury so this is coming
down straight from the attorney general
who works for Biden now you can the
Optics are kind of [__] well so it's
technically a special counsel which is
supposed to be independent uh because
because of this well Marlin uh that
Marlin
Garland Garland yeah the special counsel
still reports to the AG so if Biden told
him not to prosecute he wouldn't I mean
let's get
yeah let's get [__] real it's like
yeah they'll do whatever he tells me
yeah if Biden didn't want him being
prosecuted he would mean 100 so the
letter of the law that I don't think
that's true but you know the Attorney
General does what Biden tells him to do
it's supposed to be someone independent
but it's all
come on come on so so the Optics are
pretty bad even though obviously
this is well deserved uh but you have
Biden who is about to or who indicted
his biggest political rival in the
upcoming campaign
that's never happened before and as as
deserved as it is it it is going to be
really funky uh spicy like the calm the
discourse is going to be so toxic and so
[__] up
that I don't even know man
somebody's going to try and break them
out of jail I'm gonna call that right
now you think so I think there'll be
like some dramatic like
rescue up
run by some they wouldn't put him in
jail though they probably put him house
arrest or something they can't how do
you put a president in jail
uh
uh don't they have like 20 Secret
Service guys with them well we talked
about this when he got indicted recently
for the other crimes that he did in New
York and yeah I believe the deal would
be that Secret Service agents would need
to go into prison with him
like they wouldn't be arrested but they
would have to like
on shifts I guess show up at the prison
and they're not they're not even they're
not going to put them in jail there's no
shot it's just there's not happening he
can he might get sentenced but I have a
feeling it'd be house arrest or some
kind of thing yeah maybe you can't put a
president in jail it's crazy I mean life
in
house arrest
who knows though this is all Uncharted
Territory yeah
no no no so yeah a grand jury indicted
him yada yada the indictment includes
several charges yada yada we did that
yeah yeah
I mean that's all but we know for now
essentially well Trump put out a video
response truth social which rules
uh as you can imagine
and I gotta say super low energy from
dawn really low energy zero is
totally corrupt this is election
interference and a continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time
well it never really ended well reach
what a what do you think about witch
hunts if you ask uh we've talked about
burning the witch yeah you know the era
where we used to burn the witch that
area never really stopped I guess I wish
we was burning changed right
okay yeah that that makes sense the
tracks
the decline
and yet yo they're straight up probably
like two cartons of classified documents
blending on one a popular president a
president that got more votes than any
sitting president in the history of Our
Country Joe Biden
also ethereal has been saying this stuff
for years now yeah yeah totally this is
jukebox
ended much better the second time in the
election than
the first
and they go after him on a boxer's house
just like the Russia Russia Russia hoax
and all of the others this has been
going on for seven years that they can't
stop because it's election interference
at the highest level there's never been
anything like what's happened I'm an
innocent man I'm an innocent person they
had the Mueller hoax the Mueller report
and that came out no collusion after two
and a half years that was set up by
Hillary Clinton and Democrats but this
is what they do this is what they low
energy yeah yeah
the ridge is gone yeah no Pizzazz at all
you used to have such swag you'd be like
listen
Hillary's a fat [__] he's a cow she's
ugly he seems defeated right
there's a lot of work in the morning but
he's like 79 or something 78 he's old
76. 76. like the Year this country was
born what a patriot
yep
do so well if they would devote their
energies to honesty and integrity Joe
Biden is a giant
have you seen Joe Biden walk he fell
he's a he's a mess he's he's restarted
no no no no we'll be a lot better for
our country they could do a lot better
they could do
it when you look at what's happened to
our country in the last three years we
were energy independent we had a strong
military that wasn't woke we were doing
so well we were respected all over the
world if the biggest tax cuts in history
biggest regulation Cuts in history
now what do you do you have a president
where an election was taken got more of
the [__] dude
he's just spinning the wheels like well
you don't even know what you're saying
anymore dude that's that's it he needs
new material yeah because he can't he
can't come out
with the same [__] he's never gonna get
elected on this he already lost on this
this is the biggest Witch Hunt of all is
the biggest switch on trust me we said
his Adderall prescription ran out that's
true era where we used to burn the witch
yeah that's a good observation
any sitting president in history by far
never anything even close
and they come after me because now we're
leading in the polls Again by a lot
against Biden is that true
he's leading in the polls against Biden
I don't think that's true I think
Biden's leading him
you know not that well he not that he
wouldn't lie about it yeah
I mean Biden's pretty unpopular so I
wouldn't say it's totally out of the
question but obviously we're so far out
they're both pretty young matter
hmm
let's see against the Republicans by a
lot but we're leading against Biden by a
lot a tremendous amount a tremendous a
lot it's just a lot it's tremendous I
just don't think that it really is much
polling going on for the General yet all
the polling is for the uh primary you
know him against the santis and although
he's ahead by a tremendous amount
tremendous we went up to a level that
they figured the way they're going to
stop us is by using what's called
Warfare
what is is Warfare for the law and we
can't let it happen we can't let it
happen our country is going to hell and
they come after Donald Trump weaponizing
the justice department
weaponizing the FBI we can't let this
continue to go on because it's ripping
our country to shreds yes we have such
big problems and this should be one of
them it's a hoax the whole thing is a
hoax just like Russia Russia Russia just
like the fake dossier was a hoax right
you saw the Durham okay Grandpa you saw
the Mueller report
did you see the new uh Avengers movie
and they lost and we won all right and
we're in tremendous support but that was
a hoax and a scam hey Grandpa I heard
the Lunch is ready
seven years even after I'm out all right
it's called election interference I know
they're trying to destroy arrest before
so they could win an election
[Music]
so I just want to tell you I'm an
innocent man I write nothing wrong I
know and we'll fight this out just like
we've been Party come sit with Grandpa
wonderful if we could devote our
full-time right to making America great
again absolutely and that's exactly come
here
country is in Decline I got you we're
failing Grandpa's funeral and this is
what they do right I'm an innocent man
okay Grandpa you said this yeah he's
improving it and here we go Grandpa did
you take your meds this morning but
that's the way it is I just okay well
Connie's here she's gonna sit okay you
can continue talking to her okay so
special so nice to see you Grandpa
America First you gotta go and that's
why we were in a position unfortunately
in that position it's no longer valid
because they've done such important
you're right yeah we're in a position
yeah we're going to make America great
again don't worry Grandpa everybody
very very soundly and hopefully very
quickly thank you very much yeah yeah
okay let's do it all right
wait where did you come from
because we're on true social baby
more great content
so there's his statement
uh let's see
the Republicans right now have a bizarre
conundrum are they going to have to
reckon with there's nothing that
prohibits someone oh yeah so he can run
for president of course yeah because
he's been indicted I mean he's not been
convicted of anything
no that also doesn't matter
that's what that's what I'm trying to
say
well they'll say he didn't do anything
wrong of course he'll still run
no but I'm saying even if he's convicted
he could still no I understand right
uh here is Joe Biden people are not down
with Joe why can you run if you're
convicted of something it's just not
written down there's no just not a lot
prohibit the the requirements to be the
president are written very clearly in
the Constitution and none of it says you
can't be a criminal they never thought
that they would have to write such a
thing I think yeah they just assumed but
uh oh my God that's the world we live in
now
let's see DeSantis is
doing pretty bad still I'm gonna wake up
wake up to Santa's yeah that's the uh I
did find here um you can pull this up
these are recent uh
what do you call it
I don't know what you call it recent
Trump versus uh Biden polling so this
one has Trump up a little bit these ones
have bite it up a little bit like it's
dead yeah it's kind of dead heat Trump
up Biden up 15. oh that's against
DeSantis yeah DeSantis is [__] cooked
dude I love DeSantis yeah he's such a
child and up so you know it's a
tremendous lead it's a tremendous lead
tremendous
okay let's talk about the alien [__]
we'll move on to something fun right all
right
yes the alien [__] yeah so you're a
Believer now know us right that's what
you said let me crack open a pickle
crack open
these pickles look like little aliens
Little Green Man
crunchy little [__] like to bottle
them up with some dill and vinegar
I think a bite out of them
um can I actually can I run and peeve
really quickly no
oh no
um
any plans this weekend no I got no plans
should make some plans hmm
hopefully I don't have covid
at this point it's three days that
you're negative and no symptoms I was
exposed on Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday I'm on my third day but they say
three to five days yeah is the
incubation period
I'm just I'm feeling pretty hopeful I
feel like if I'd not positive tomorrow
morning yeah then I mean come on right
yeah
I think so
I'm just constantly confused because
I've been sick I had this throat thing
that I'm still recovering from I know
but it's almost like way before that
started way before no I know I I'm not
saying that that's the covet I'm just
confused because sometimes I feel
something I'm like oh [__] am I getting
sick right but no
no
just getting better
I tell you what though I do not want
covid twice that is that [__] disease
is [__] up
it has they're starting to find out more
and more about like long-term
consequences of it and
I do not want covet again yeah and I
want the kids to have covered again
either
so
shout out to my lawyer shout out to
coven
all right on to the aliens talk about
aliens so this happened about a week ago
April 20th or no that's two months ago
yeah no it uh the actual incident
happened a while ago it's just all of
the footage from the police and
everything came out the other day so now
it's making making this happened on
April 30th
around 11 50 pm
Las Vegas police officers body cameras
recorded
something streaking low across the sky
something was entering Earth
from outer space it looks like
about 40 minutes later a man called
9-1-1 saying he and his family saw
something fall from the sky and that
there were two moving
non-human things in his backyard that
were very tall like like eight to ten
feet
[Music]
now here's the uh first of all
where's the video of the the falling
debris because I've seen that one I
don't see it in here
[Music]
um it's you talk in the body cam footage
it's in here the uh
for one sec hey he's looking like an
alien right now
my face is on fire
did you eat bread or what what happened
to you it's this is from caffeine a
Starbucks drink
wait so the caffeine does it too and the
gluten so I went to the doctor on
Tuesday and he just said uh
he said oh yeah that happens to me too
it's either because of stress causes it
and other things like caffeine could uh
can make it worse so yeah there's
nothing there's no cure for it so it's
not gluten related it could be he's he
uh prescribed me uh allergy test as well
can I just point something out real
quick yes
oh my God
that is uh that is wow that is quite
compelling I have to admit yeah
that is quite good
all right so
I was trying to find a cleaner one but I
have one from the New York just tell me
which one it is
I I guess it's included in the long
video of the the kid who called in
talking about it okay whatever here it
is
what this one's I've seen way better
ones
this is like a light that's a that's
it's only from the body cam yeah no I've
seen other people who recorded it
[Music]
that it looked way better
okay so there it is but try to find
another angle because okay it looks much
better so here is uh that when they
called the police okay okay
here's the phone call
Big Lot outside right correct okay okay
we're working and we just see in a
corner something falls on from the sky
and there was wood light and when I hit
down it was like a big impact and we
felt it we feel like an energy and then
and then and then we hear like a lot of
footsteps near us and then we have a big
a big uh equipment and we see and
there's a there's like an eight foot
person beside it and another one's
inside and it has big eyes and looking
at us and it's still there okay where is
this on your property
uh and I'm in my backyard I swear to God
this is not a joke this is actually
terrified so there's two people or two
subjects that are in your backyard
correct and they're very large they're
like eight foot nine feet I don't know
they look like aliens big eyes they have
big eyes like like I can't explain it
and make our mouths
they're shiny eyes and and they're not
human they're 100 they're not human
could he not record them look so he did
apparently and so we're gonna get to
that wait was that the video where
they're supposedly in no okay so here's
that was that was the police body cam
footage when they arrived at the house
okay why is
hold on I gotta show you something
what the [__] I'm gonna show you guys
behind the scenes a little bit
when I hover my mouse over this this is
the video he uploaded
just the thumbnail
[Laughter]
what the [__]
I do not know why that happened it's
cast from an earlier link or something
so here is the video he took it's so
funny everybody in the chat was also
bothered by the okay lady I was too and
I don't even know why
at the beginning yeah in the beginning
he's like okay lady wait on the on the
911 call yeah first thing he says she
goes 9-1-1 he goes okay he calls her
lady now here's something that we need
to consider
a lot of people are saying it's so fake
I'm just gonna already put it out there
wait till you see okay
did you find a better version of the
falling [__]
I'm not saying any other version besides
the ring camera footage which is in this
video you have highlighted but those are
the only two I've seen yeah
yeah I didn't see it's in this one
yeah okay so that has the ring that has
the ring footage
listen to this
now this channel is called alien
society51 okay it has one video on it
and I'll tell you something interesting
this is the dude who called 9-1-1 he has
the his YouTube channel is alien Society
yeah it's a bit of a red flag to
wouldn't you say
he's got a watermark and everything
so here's the video
hello everybody Welcome to my channel
yeah they're nothing this is the guy
that's him that's the area that's the
guy that's my first video I'm here to
tell you what happened to me on May 1st
I'm not trying to explain the best of my
abilities this is pretty long I'm not
gonna watch this whole damn thing that's
slow and boring here's the video
the light
video
so
what okay so there it is okay that's
pretty good
here's a ring camera video you could
hear the bang
this is around the neighborhood so
here's the video definitely something
fell from this guy no question about it
yo what all right
why the yo when have you ever seen ring
video this low quality
what is this it's weird because you see
the above was like text that is not part
of the video that's also shitty so it's
like obviously a filter on top of it you
know what I know what I'm looking at
yeah it's a car in a driveway no but
what is above it's like a tweet it's
like a screen it's like a screen
recording of a Facebook post it's not
the original video oh so he doesn't have
the original yeah I think this must have
been someone else in the name well can
you find the original video
not based off of that
well this video doesn't show anything
anyways it's just it's just for the the
fact that well I just want to know why
is it that every time someone claims to
have seen an alien the footage is always
like 10 not showing it it's not showing
it I'm just saying all media pictures
video they're like sorry we put capped
out at 10 pixels you're saying all this
but you're gonna feel so silly when you
see the slam dunk evidence all I ask for
if you're gonna tell me that aliens are
here on Earth
which is an extraordinary claim
but I'm open to it
just one pick just one HD photo
just one uh chip that fell out because
these these UFOs are apparently they're
crashing into Earth all the time these
aliens that can have mastered
Interstellar space travel they can't
they just can't deal with Earth's
gravity
they're always crashing in the Earth
yeah and there's never any little bit of
Peace of something alien
an HD photo nobody can get me an HD
photo
it all looks like this
okay
the one aspect of the story that we
haven't mentioned yet is that the police
officer who responded to the call said
that his partner also noticed something
falling from the sky and that was the
only reason he was even pursuing it in
the way that he did because his partner
said that he saw it too right they
wouldn't have taken it seriously but
they themselves have witnessed something
crashing or something definitely crashed
from the sky that part's true
go back a little bit
oh this is it this is the slam dunk
footage right here already yeah I think
we have the other link where it's in
slow motion so we can go yeah below it
okay this is the video because I was
like he's like yo there's two massive
aliens in my backyard I was like get
your camera yeah exactly everybody's got
a [__] iPhone on them
people are getting footage of the most
obscenely obscure [__] you ask yourself
how'd they get footage of that how why
were you even filming no when there's
two massive 10-foot aliens in your
backyard we can't get them we just
couldn't get him on Photo just couldn't
do it you're gonna feel sorry to see the
backyard area you can see you cannot see
it too good but on camera but it's there
here's a video
thank you sir okay
what did you see it but it's after the
video me and my brother went to go pick
up my tools
then my brother calls me and he told he
told me shakingly look behind the
forklift so I look you see it keep in
mind
and then I see the alien creature
so when I saw it
it was a tall skinny lengthy creature
and why do they always look like like
how they're portrayed was he a skinny
Legend and like he was a student yeah
here when she well the the media why are
they always tall lengthy with big eyes
because that's what they really look
like and all of that's there's
commonalities in all of the close
encounters that people have and it you
know fairly accurate representation has
emerged here I actually just uh enhanced
the footage let me let me drop that real
quick so you can get a better picture
enhance thank you Kim okay this is
interesting
aliens here for the first time
[Music]
kids
it never did a hearing I love it
um
So This Is It Love
yeah this is a screenshot from what is
this a deep space Hubble this is the
image of the first glimpse of the
universe there it is so funny There It
Is here's the Big Bang if you look back
deep enough and the universe's history
of the background radiation
oh my God okay wait are you spooked
looking at that because I am yeah here's
the Andromeda galaxy this is the
creation of the first I
of an alien
so let's see here uh that's great
greenish color
and when I looked that in the eyes my
body just froze really
like the same way the same experience as
having sleep houses keep in mind I'm
staring now I I believe this kid
um thinks
believes what he's saying you think so I
think so maybe I don't know I don't know
listen wait who cares either way yeah
you're better you're obviously
expressing skepticism I'm I'm kind of
jokingly saying that I'm a Believer or
whatever what I will say about this
video is it is interesting that the
whole family is freaked out by something
because like that's unusual it's
probably something there right but these
stories it almost always is somebody's
out by themselves in something crazy
happens to them and it is interesting to
me that there's like five people that
all think that there's probably
something there because yeah I'm playing
like a rock fell from the sky
I think I found the ring footage if you
I sent it I think so you actually found
the OG I found a screenshot now here's
scary ring footage [__] forget about
aliens big Nick and murder porn guys
show up in here front door at 3am there
seriously oh
bro holy [__]
[Music]
there is no UFO crash that would scare
me as much as this
[Music]
all right so uh here apparently is
the alien opening his mouth
it's so funny
right yo not even dead that's it I see
it
holy [__] love the quality
so this this is uh actually our best
photo of an alien so yeah this is
exciting guys legit
first Contact this is super exciting we
finally got a HD photo of alien
feels like an April person beside it and
another one's inside and it has big eyes
and looking at us and it's still there
okay where is this is your property he's
showing the 911 call again why do we
need to see a screenshot of the 9-1-1
did he record his 9-1-1 calls this makes
me suspicious
he make 9-1-1 a contact
save the contact in his phone
it is interesting thing I know the
number you're right that he recorded so
clear it was like sharp why would he
exactly that's HD why there's plenty of
pixels in that image but yeah why would
he record the 9-1-1 call
well not I don't think he did I don't
think it's he's just showing that he
called this is sitting in a screenshot I
mean I don't think anybody doubted the
call where'd the audio come from then I
don't know probably like for you you're
right that takes time but it was a long
time ago it happened it was only a month
ago boy it takes well so no I think that
wait a minute the 911 call was released
by the police at the same time that they
released the body cam footage right yeah
that we know where that audio came from
actually and in order to comprehend
you're gonna have to break something
yeah the
omelet of knowledge
by the way if you guys peep any other
great uh Abba and preach uh deep moments
please send it to us
I want more deepness
they get like half a million views or
something or when they're not talking
about me or Hassan or fresh and fit
they get half a million but if they talk
about me or Hassan then they get a
million so I understand why they talk
about me so much how you just look
stupid
yeah I mean look at this one when he's
talking about some other [__] it's like
370.
nobody cares but then all of a sudden
Ethan Klein oh this is their dumb
re-upload all of a sudden Ethan's
threatening us 1.2 million hmm
interesting I wonder why you made eight
videos about me that is a spicy title
though
and then you have to hand it to him yeah
yeah I hand it to him Ethan's
threatening us
fire
there we go here's the body cam of the
officer and now it's more than an hour
after that bright light officers meeting
up with the caller and his family what'd
you see
it was like a
preacher yeah
like one of my partners said they saw
something followed this guy too so
that's why I'm kind of curious did you
see anything Landing in your backyard or
do you see like a big deal what they say
they see like a big uh like a big
something with like what I saw right
let's walk into the backyard to
investigate but Metro so they went in
the back oh this was an interesting
detail he cut off the video right there
but I saw that report when they go in
the backyard they censored it they like
blacked it out oh it said because it's
private property correct yeah since when
does
if it's private property they can't uh I
guess show it have we not all seen
tons of footage of cops running through
people's backyards and police cam
footage and stuff I feel like we have
yeah that's what they said though
a little Saucy that's true how would the
show Cops exist
you know what I mean like well most of
it takes place in public space
no they're going people's houses all the
times
because it's it's a horrible show but I
used to watch tons of cops
what if they have a warrant do they have
warrants and cops is that why
I don't know you need warrants to go in
their house I mean they were invited to
go uh who cares who cares yeah I've seen
cars of the salt light what's clear
they're taking this call seriously hey
this might sound like a really dumb
question but did you guys see anything
fall out of the sky asking others what
they saw yeah
so uh
uh I definitely was an incident of like
a meteor falling or something that got
everybody in the neighbor neighborhood
spooked about it and then this one
family thinks they they saw aliens this
one dude with the channel called alien
Society 51 where she saw alien in his
backyard uh
then the other officer came here
's a video of him talking to my family
it does it does nine foot Bings come
back don't call us all right deal with
it yourself
[__] a cab coward
your [__] job man
go out in that field with your pistol
drawn
coward for the left one of the officers
told me
if I see the thing again
so don't call him just shoot him
and you can hear in the video here's the
video it does not yeah we saw it he was
kidding it was a joke
please come back don't call
don't call yourself
say shoot it by the way
they'll never mention anything about
firing a gun yeah he gave me the
authority to shoot anyone in my body he
actually deputize me I'm actually a
police officer now I'll be standing my
ground officer thank you for permission
to kill
I ain't dealing with that
so they left and we went inside the
house and we started praying as we're
praying you can hear a loud human like
scream in the backyard
is that right this is what happened to
me on May 1st 2023 I hope you guys can
understand what happened to me I know
it's hard to believe oh we don't get to
hear the scream but I saw what I saw and
it's kind of going viral that's why I'm
here to explain the story I did an
interview with journalist doc Papa yeah
so this is kind of popping off on social
media people are thinking hey this is
this is finally the evidence we've been
looking for and here I'm gonna do
something for you guys I'm going to slow
down yeah the footage so that we can
really see the alien
the 10-foot alien
okay
frame by frame
wow wow oh my God
oh my God
that's HD man there's tears in my eyes
this is the HD footage we've been
waiting for
this these frames are particularly
useful
so did we see the aliens supposedly or
not yet uh you didn't see it
wait you don't see it you [__] idiot
is this where is the frame with the
alien I just he's right there in the
white shirt
it's right in front of you dude
you see it
jokes aside I have no idea where the
alien's supposed to be
there's some time stamps uh in the
comments yeah because this is a YouTube
video if you look at the replies uh
everyone in the reply sees it which is
incredible actually so let's see you can
refer to them to see what they think I
let a version freeze frame with outline
I'm torna weather is the alien figure
just a person standing behind the car
waving their arms up oh it's another
video let's see
they see all that
a person waving their arms up
this is like [__] Mass paranoia
dude oh there's more still slower
that is not there
that is just not there
oh man
oh my gosh what is the alien doing
exactly what'd you say
also that's pretty conclusive if the
alien is like 10 feet tall it's kind of
weird that that doesn't line up yeah a
car would be like what six feet yeah
he's raining math [__] right here this
is the most compelling evidence we have
seen today
also he said there there was a human
scream in his backyard right yeah yeah
so maybe it's a human in your back here
that makes sense
Black Mass slash blob there it is
very good very compelling we love that
so uh let's see
uh that's about it eh
that's about it uh I guess there is the
mention of the uh because aliens are all
over the news this last week uh oh there
was another alien whistleblower
let's take a look here
can I read this without okay yeah
well I saw a video of him talking I
gotta read this whole article
I think it was on Joe Rogan or one of
these dumb [__] shows talking David
grush his name is garoosh
he this guy is claiming let's see he
worked for
gooch good
this guy worked for
I think it was FBI uh or NSA I think it
was NSA so anyway he he's not working
there anymore and he's like yeah we uh
found a bunch of UFOs and alien bodies
we got him
and I mean he's not the first person to
do that there was that other guy
who's been just making the biggest
Shilling ever yeah uh
[Music]
um
or no he's even newer than that I think
hold on pablazar yeah bubbles are almost
a long time he's the OG he's a real
goofy looking dude
no not wait no not Bob I think I know
exactly who you're talking about his
name is escaping me right now
um Stephen Greer yes Stephen Greer
that's who you're I think that's who
you're thinking about
listen this is him it lists him as a UFO
ologist [__] that is not a thing
right bro so I did a uh it's been long
enough that I find talking about this
now I did a uh
like a seminar of his you worked it oh
at a place in Palm Springs years ago yo
Palm Springs is it is there's a lot of
alien house there uh according to him
yes yeah and the whole thing was
basically it was like one of those
things where it's like come to my talk
I think I think it was a paid thing but
it wasn't very expensive but the whole
thing was a pitch for him to take you
out for a weekend to go see aliens out
in the desert or something and it was
like
pay me five thousand dollars and I'll
take you camping yeah and we'll
definitely 100 see alien yeah I'm sure
they saw it man that's true I've seen
all kinds of HD photographs for that
during those outings
um yeah this guy's a total con man he
used to work in government and then he
came out and was like yeah there's uh
super molecules that they use for the
engines and
he's just a [__] con man it's crazy
and then idiots like Joe Rogan platform
him and now he's like super he was
uh
huge [__] [__] to me and everybody
else that was working the event really
such a prick go on like
and frankly he was kind of a dick to the
people that were there for him too he's
he's kind of psycho he was like very
like controlling and he was like doing
the talking and if like it was like a
teacher the way like if somebody like
whispered something in the audience he
would like stop and be like what was
that God I hate what was that would do
that do you have something to say I
you have something to say you know just
like stare them down he was like he was
[__] psycho dude this dude I mean to
be fair he's giving me like one of these
guys in Men In Black where there's a
tiny alien yeah
[Music]
looks weird
so that's him
and then the new guy who's the new guy
the new kid oh here it is here's the
interview thank you this is our boy Mick
West friend of the show
uh he came on the show a long time ago
yeah yeah skeptic he's like the the yeah
he's honestly like Enemy Number One to
this whole Community too he's a smart
guy he knows his [__] so here this is
the new guy he's an Air Force veteran
wow
[__] we better believe him do we have
species oh well naturally
um when you recover something that's
either landed or crashed
um sometimes you encounter dead pilots
and believe it or not as fan as
Fantastical as that sounds
it's true
do we have bodies do we have
he's saying dead he's saying alien body
species oh well naturally he's saying
the alien Pilots yeah I was confused
what he meant
there's more videos of this interview
it's all pretty pretty crazy
uh yeah uh Mick says never mind flank
saucers this dude says we have dead
Pilots of alien crafts unfortunately
he's not seen them or any photos of them
the craft or the technology but
nonetheless he assures us it's true yeah
that's my problem with all this
just give me something yeah
I want to believe I want to believe man
yeah totally
so where the [__] did the guardian write
up about this
whistlebola claims the US has alien
vehicles but where's the proof okay I
don't care whatever I'm not reading that
old thing
I have to tell you something I'm feeling
a little bit fatigued
do you think that could be a symptom of
certainly it could be it could be yeah
yeah covert is just weird I'm feeling a
little like drained
maybe you should go take another test
yeah you think of it do we have a test
here I'll take it right now
I think we have one in the kitchen I
think we do let me go look
covid-19 also uh we have been going for
about two and a half hours so we could
you could go take a little nappy at home
if you want let's do a test and wait for
the results uh let me see if I can
Gordon jeters oh wait right so I'll go
do that oh Gabe's in lobby yeah yeah um
here let me set that up first and then
I'll go find you a test
bro
everything is from the pickles
too much pickle juice
so there it is I want that oh here's
Gabe he's joining the uh oh that's nice
Gabe welcome we got the Bobbies okay
thanks for the pickles absolutely man my
pleasure I've been hooking up hooking
you up a lot lately oh yeah all right so
here's what we're here's how we do this
um shake the jar up so that all the
stuff on the bottom is mixed in so it
looks real cloudy yeah good
yeah boy okay open the crack that crack
that dirty dude open oh it's been opened
already yeah I almost did that already
did you smell it did you do anything
with it
no I just I just smell it and it seems
like it seems like it's like right other
pimples babe maybe this one will be
different so get yourself a nice small
one I find those ones are the are the
nicest crunchiest yeah oh it's pretty
big that's pretty big they're all big no
no there's nice little ones in there I
swear
I can't find huh dig in there deep now
with those tongs
get in there work it work it
this one is good I can't see it's King
out yeah it's probably fine yeah all
right
all right so Gabe is
going in
for the big bite the big reveal now take
a small bite it doesn't need to be big
yeah just crunch off the tip there you
go make it slow
enjoy the texture the crunchy texture
nice texture right crunchy
we're actually about
I don't know
gave his drill a little bit and he spit
it out
I tried it you actually you know what
you tried you really did you gave that a
great effort
you put it in there you crunched it
around and I'm very proud of you for
that thank you
all right well you have two cans of
pickles hopefully someone in your house
likes pickles I'm sure there's a lot of
people that likes pickles yeah
yeah hey hey Gabe would you ever drink a
pickle flavored white claw
no
what if we wrote the last what was the
last white Claw on Earth
the last white claw I'm still not trying
it right
what if you were starving on an island
and all the only food you had was
pickles
well I probably I probably would have to
sacrifice myself a little bit that's a
trick question Gabe pickles have zero
calories
hey it is
all right buddy thanks for trying those
pickles okay all right thanks
yeah yeah [__]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody on the council salute Gabe
please all of you throw up this Solution
that's awesome ready and you're gonna do
let's all put out up and on three or on
zero you gotta do the the salute part so
three two one salute
uh nice try yeah whatever Captain uh
White claw thank you
all right you're all awesome baby thanks
bro so
um unfortunate news uh the last covet
test was uh you took the other day here
at the office so we are oh [__] order
more buddy it won't be here until next
week wait you're still here
you can hang out if you want
you want to hang out
oh sure yeah [__] yeah baby you're on
the council now he's giving me the uh
dive from Power Rangers you know how
they have that big dude yeah yeah that's
Gabe Gabe you want me to talk about
woman gets eye drops caught in her eye
wait I think he just bailed oh he's out
damn okay
maybe I should go home and yeah I think
you you I mean I don't wanna again we're
approaching three hours it's not really
if it's under three hours it's not a
show
it is under but um I would still
qualifies this show
we talked about all our headlines
come on it's Friday baby
how long we've been going
two hours and 40 minutes oh yeah I don't
know if I can do another 20 minutes
I think I need to go home and take a
test all right just do that then
you need some more papers bro at least I
got to do the Fret let's see I'm maybe
I'm just
maybe that burrito is just hitting me
wrong
awesome I'm sweating I have a headache
my body's starting to ache
the
yeah that's like coffee all right let's
just go it's not a lot but it I do feel
where before I didn't feel it yeah right
now I feel it
so if I have covered what do we do like
theoretically what happens nothing you
just you get sick yeah it's just because
like usually I would stay away from the
kids in Ila right but I've been with
them
so that's
remember we're remembering why covet's a
big deal
right now in real time right because it
spreads horribly and while you're not
yet sick so you don't even realize
you're spreading it
oh [__] me dude I mean I'm glad that we
if yeah we made the right call to uh
Institute the council here
there's always a seat on the council for
you duh I feel I got a bad feeling about
this
that happened the last time I got
covered I was like oh [__] I think I got
it
I actually remember that happening same
thing on the show
weren't you just like suddenly no no it
hit me that evening I started feeling
like my body's sore and then I took the
test
and it was like a really faint line yeah
yeah
bad boy bad boy what you gonna do
[__] my tits call me Nancy
anybody want to take me up on that
whatever you need I'm at 207.
I don't know
where I last reported in at but I'm at
207. I think all right number two or
nine last yeah I think she was I was
gonna say 209. 207. I Kobe will probably
helped me lose weight that's a Vibe oh
yeah
just [__] and not eat
of that for me
uh so I can't just disappear in the
basement
[Applause]
um let's go take a test
and see because if it happens if I'm
positive I can go in the basement and
then hopefully if you do get sick I'll
be better by then and we can swap out
I don't know
can someone send me the tick tock of the
last time I had coven I did the basement
Drake thing this is this I kind of think
back
but everybody still got sick everybody
got it bad so I just don't know what's
the point of
even doing that I just like I've been
wearing a mask like how am I gonna sit
around the kids if I'm positive it just
seems weird if they're not sick it just
seems like it just seems like super
risky even though you're right they've
been like exposed a lot I have been
wearing a mask at home
but
it does feel weird to sit with them if I
know I have covet I don't know
you know what I mean
I don't like speculating
[Music]
so so I'm feeling a little bit nostalgic
for this
for these days Ela
these were the days by
I was so [__] sick
and these were the days when alfredo
would come in the basement too
Alfredo won't come in the basement
anymore so weird yeah it's been like
half a year one day he was just like I
will not go in the basement ever for any
reason he won't go down there go down
with trees or go down with food if you
like carry him down there he like
Sprints up yeah what the [__] is this
that's so weird that is weird I can't
figure out what you should be down there
all the time when I he had no problem he
came down yeah and then I I ca I don't
know what could have possibly
I even asked the vet about it I was like
is this weird
and she's like can he do the stairs on
yeah he goes upstairs and downstairs no
problem
very strange you're actually thinking
he's like the longer we sit here I'm
catching it from you right now
just saying
all right let's wrap it up I don't know
what we're doing wrap it up okay guys
thank you I'll update you guys uh
obviously on like
stories or something or Twitter
thank you guys for watching
thank you to my lawyers
[Music]
thank you to the members the loyal
fubotroopers and everybody on the
council
give it up for the council folks thank
you to Bobby
thank you Bobby makes the best damn
pickles love you Bobby miss you every
day
sorry about a little shorter episode but
we might have a Calamity to deal with
we shall see
but uh either way hopefully I'll be
seeing you guys on Monday
[Music]
live shows right around the corner yeah
where we capture next we're starting to
put a lot of work into planning and
getting ready for that I'm very excited
I think we got a fun show planned I
think we got a banger it's gonna be a
good time yeah lots of surprises and
reminder
even if you didn't get a ticket we will
be streaming it so you won't miss
something of course we wouldn't dream of
leaving actually you will miss the thing
because well
no it won't be missing out well there's
one thing well whatever
but we would never dream of leaving you
guys out
but um also I haven't mentioned this but
we're going to be doing the same sample
sale Teddy fresh thing at the merch
counter
so
that that was really fun last time we'll
be doing that again but okay anyway
see you guys on Monday have a great
weekend [__] baby hope you have a good
night
[Music]